foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
when they're banning and burning books
that
is the slow snowball
fascism
the county in Florida moms of fascism as
they should be called
moms of fascism move to band eight nor
Robert's books and public libraries uh
Nora Roberts responds online but this is
you know this isn't just a story about
Nora Roberts books there are many books
that the Republican fascists the real
America First Nazis are trying to ban
and that's what we should be paying
attention to not only are they trying to
ban books they're trying to ban drag
shows they're trying to ban Women's
Health Care which they are successful
in a lot of these red States they're
becoming having success and they're
going to keep doing it
the only standing the only thing
standing in their way is the
pro-democracy coalition
to fight for liberty freedom
rights
yesterday even in the United States
Senate
the real America First Nazi party
the Republicans in the Senate vote no
on the era now if you're not familiar
with the era
let me let me just get you up to speed
here in 1923 this was introduced
to give equal rights to women in the
Constitution
to put it in the Constitution it wasn't
until 1972 that it was passed
only up until recently was the 38th
state which was Virginia
able to ratify the era the Equal Rights
Amendment which would be the 28th if
maga's out there and they can't count it
would be the 28th Amendment to our
constitution
giving women
the actual equal rights inside the
Constitution itself
not just in the courts but in the actual
document amending it it's what it means
to change
foreign
it's really bad when we have to do the
definition I gotta play Mr Webster here
on the Tony Michaels podcast
give them the definitions to words
yesterday
the United States Senate not moved to
pass the era it has been passed since
1972.
an amendment has to be ratified by
two-thirds of the states
the problem is is that the era
was ratified by the proper number of
states just not by the deadline in the
1972 Amendment
yesterday
it was brought to the floor and it was
it was struck down for closure
we're not even talking about voting on
the bill to move the bill to a vote
they couldn't get break 60 only two
Republicans Collins and murkowski voted
to change the deadline
on the ERA this wasn't voting for equal
rights or not vote they wouldn't change
the deadline of a ratified Amendment
and you're wonder you're standing around
still wondering who the [__] traitors
are you're still standing around
wondering who's for Liberty and freedom
get the [__] out of here with that [__]
if if look if you if you're not aware
that the [__] Bannon books and
the [__] voting to make sure
that a ratified amendment has a deadline
that changes so it can go into effect in
our constitution if you're not if you're
completely unaware that they're the
[__] right-wing fascist
you're lost you're [__] lost
more fascism in Montana
representative Zephyr
is banned from the floor from debate
because they don't want her voice heard
they don't want the world to hear from
her
yesterday in a TR in a true Nazi move
the speaker tries to ban her from a
public bench
you know in the South during segregation
black folks couldn't sit in a certain
spot on the bus
do you do you do you even understand
what the [__] they're trying to do I've
been yelling and screaming it
for two [__] years into this
microphone
I'm telling you they're coming for your
[__] it ain't just women and it's not
just trans people
they're coming for your parental consent
they're coming they're coming for your
education
they're coming for your mind they're
coming for your dress code
they're coming for your sexuality
they're coming for all of it
all of it
and they're not gonna [__] stop
they they won't quit folks we are the
only thing standing in the way of the
Nazis
and killing our Liberty that's it the
pro-democracy coalition
that is it it is us
it's the majority by the way
and that's the other stupid [__] lie
I'm tired of hearing
dumb stupid ass [__] that somehow
someway Donald Trump is popular in this
country get the [__] out of here with
that nonsense
what a bunch of dribble
I'm gonna
I'm gonna show you a clip today
uh of Donald Trump seemingly trying to
[__] his pants I'm not sure exactly what
he's doing here I don't know what the
context of it is it seems like he thinks
he's trying to lift weights or something
apparently it has to do with his
transphobia that he has that all these
right Wingers have where they're
absolutely [__] obsessed
with other people's genitalia in
particular women who they think are sexy
that may have a penis or not they they
can't tell they're not really sure how
it affects their own sexuality they're
confused
to me it looks like he's [__] his
pants that's what it looks like to me
I don't know I mean it looks like he's
feeling his [__] diaper
what else am I supposed to think you've
seen this clip right
but there's so many more clips from
yesterday from an interview that this
[__] bonehead did
um better newsworthy then I'm gonna show
you those too and from Jack Smith from
Mike Pence's testimony and he's
terrified oh my God he's completely
[__] frightened that Mike Pence told
the truth
so much so is he's like
hey Mike that's a nice fly on your head
be ashamed if something happened to it
you know what I mean
he tries to play mobster and he's
horrible at it he's [__] horrible at
it that's why I stopped calling him the
Cheeto I stopped calling him the Cheeto
dusk mobster and I started calling him
the Cheeto dust q and honor because he's
not even good at pretending to be a
monster really he's not even good at it
he's he's damn good at being a Cuban
honor he's hella good at that oh [__]
he's got that down 100 Pat boom slam
dunk on the Q Anon [__] he's got
that that's why I switched the name [__]
him [__] him it's my name anyways I can
switch the [__]
but Grandpa poopy pants in this clip
that everyone's talking about
seemingly fills his diaper listen same
[__] different diaper that's all it is
same [__] different diaper it always has
been let's see what else is in the news
they're banning books they're trying
they're kicking they're kicking trans
people off public benches
state representatives
representative Zephyr is just sitting
outside the chamber because they banned
her from the floor because they don't
want her to speak
because her truth may be to power
and so she she sets up shop outside the
chamber on a public bench and the
speaker of the house that [__]
scumbag tries to kick her off a bench
because she's trans I don't give a [__]
what you say I don't care what you say
you [__] they they're trying to
get rid of her because she's trans
and it should be a signal
to everyone Jesus Christ we went through
this just weeks ago in Tennessee when
they banned representative Jones and
representative Jones
because they were black
expelled them from the Tennessee house
floor because they were loud
well that's what they're scared of was
Zephyr
she's Loud by while being trans and we
all know that the fascist Kryptonite is
loud noises
that's why we must in unison get as loud
as we possibly can
that's most important in this time oh
yeah
speaking of fashies uh Brett Kavanaugh
oh man these [__] this Harlan
Hitler I tell you what
this Harlan Hitler
more stories about Harlan Hitler and
Brett Kavanaugh
apparently Brett Kavanaugh in the uh
probe in the Brett Kavanaugh there was a
lot of things that were omitted hmm
I wonder what those could be it really
feels like at this point
to me to me at this point that all the
right Wingers on the Supreme Court it
feels like they're a little unethical
I don't know maybe it's just me maybe
I'm off my rocker here
but and it feels like that Harlan Hitler
has a uh has a way about you know moving
his way in
on the unethical right-wingers on the
Supreme Court
I don't know
maybe it's just me
um Justice Roberts is refusing
to testify
which honestly you know this could all
be taken care of by the pro-democracy
Coalition and here's how you can do it
um you just need you just need to use
the power of your ballot it's time it's
time it's time it's time it's time it's
time 2024 is coming and there's going to
be a a huge movement a young people huge
movement of women and we should all band
together we should all get behind one
cause and it should be democracy that's
it democracy period democracy not
autocracy
and the reason why is because if we
Grant rights and Liberty to every art
and freedoms to everyone that is the
vehicle to Liberty for all Equity
equality
it's not something to be scared of it
really isn't
I mean we could welcome all kinds of
people into our Coalition folks
all kinds of people could be welcomed
into our coalition
if we just have democracy as our main
platform that's it period democracy
period
that's what I think the message should
be democracy period
it's everywhere it's everywhere oh yeah
the other uh story about Donald Trump is
that um what oh [__] is there something
happening in South Carolina Jesus Christ
every time I turn around oh yes
they're trying to um ban abortion in
South Carolina and Nebraska
oh man but it fails it fails in South
Carolina and it fails in Nebraska
it feels like it almost feels like to me
that this is unpopular
taking away Women's Health Care and
banning Women's Health Care almost
almost as unpopular as Banning books
maybe maybe maybe maybe maybe just maybe
maybe just maybe humans should have
rights like the right to read what they
want to read choose the health care they
want to choose I don't know
these are novel ideas probably
um it looks like in South Carolina five
women voted against the bill including
three Republicans
and also the Nebraska
and was just one vote shy
of um
killing abortion services and Women's
Health Care in Nebraska
the fight is long the fight is hard for
democracy it really is yeah we can't let
it down right we can't stop
we can't turn our backs on this
um we're gonna have to we're gonna have
to band together it's gonna have to
happen we we gotta stop with this stupid
[__] ageism [__] and oh it's not fair
and debate this and debate that shut the
[__] up
it's not for this nonsense
enough I'm gonna show you some clips
today of Donald Trump
that maybe May might cause you to know
what the threat is it's not it's not how
old the president is okay that's not a
threat to our democracy you people are
dumb as dog [__]
if you're out there saying that the age
of the president is a threat to
democracy you're not paying attention
stop it
the dude's opponent
is [__] old and really honestly he's
if you want to press ageism on somebody
Donald Trump looks a hell of a lot worse
for his age than Joe Biden can ever
dream at least Joe Biden can handle a
ramp for crying out loud
at least Joe Biden then at the work walk
around in [__] diapers
[__] his pants on stage act like
he's lifting weights or some [__] I
don't know what's happening there I
don't know
let me read you
let's go back to the book man thing real
quick let me read you the um the quote
from Nora Roberts Nora Roberts says if
you don't want your teenager reading
this book
that's your right as a mom
Liberty Norris for Liberty and good luck
with that but you don't have the right
to say nobody's kid can read this book
honestly when they're starting to ban
books those are the books you should
probably [__] read
it's real now I I haven't read any Nora
Roberts books I'll admit it I am not I'm
not read one nor Robert's book haven't
probably never will maybe I don't know
but I was doing a little bit of research
this morning to figure out what these
books these eight books are about
and apparently the eight books that they
want to ban the eight of them
all eight
I'm not making this [__] up all eight
end in a marriage proposal in the book
a marriage proposal
a man and a woman you know traditional
white Christian values type [__]
this isn't about Nora Roberts books
this isn't about books in general
what this is about is their power
to tell you what you can and cannot do
it's the slow snowball of fascism folks
and it's getting bigger and bigger as
it's rolling down the hill
we must stand in its way
we have to stand in its way
um I actually I'm hoping let me see let
me check I think we're gonna have a
guest at the bottom of the hour today
let me see if I've I've got a
confirmation I'm pretty sure this person
is going to be joining us uh he's been
on the show before I don't have uh just
confirmation just quite yet but here in
about 15 minutes we should have a guest
on the show
um and he's going to talk about how Elon
Musk quote tweeted him on a story about
Tucker Carlson we watched that the other
day too and today's Friday today's
Friday holy [__] I almost forgot Friday
the 28th folks Friday Friday Friday you
know what it is on Friday it's bonehead
of the week you vote you decide who is
the bonehead of the week and we break it
down right here on the Tony Michaels
podcast and I'm sure we're gonna have
some surprises
uh in the bonehead of the week my guess
is is that Stephen Crowder will make it
in I don't know if you've heard this
story about Stephen Crowder in his
divorce and um his
gender reaffirming surgery that he said
that's right uh Stephen and and I I
didn't know this about Stephen cranner
but apparently
um he's a self-admitted bisexual which
I I mean doesn't bother me a bit and I
really don't care that he had generally
confirming surgery that's cool by me but
Tucker Carlson is going to make it into
the bonehead of the week so we'll talk
about him Elon Musk and Mike Pence Mike
Pence you know testified before the
grand jury
and he wasn't able to use executive
privilege
um so and I think it was seven hours
seven hours Mike Pence was telling the
truth or perjuring himself either way my
guess is is that if we were the fly on
Mike Pence's head
we would see that Mike Pence told the
truth because he doesn't want to go to
federal prison that would be my guess
and that's why we had the result that we
had on January 6th let's see what else
is in the news it's all fast moving I'm
telling you the Brett Kavanaugh story
South Carolina uh let's see
era
again the era
a lot of people are saying that the
Republicans voted no on the era and
that's wrong that's wrong they didn't
vote no on the era they voted no
to change the deadline of a ratified
Amendment which is the era the era is
passed the era is is ratified by the
correct number of states it the only
thing that that the era needs
is to change the deadline of the
ratification so it can become an
official change of the Constitution
known as the 28th Amendment the Equal
Rights Amendment
so they didn't vote no on era era is
ratified
it just did not meet the deadline in the
bill
from 1972.
uh John Kennedy said he voted no on the
ER but but this is the thing this is the
The Rake that these [__] idiots step
on every time John Kennedy tweets I
voted no on the era here let me show you
the uh picture of it here here it is
there it is doesn't he look like a i he
kind of looks like he's got lipstick on
in this screenshot or something I don't
know you know who's counting who's
dressed up as a woman and who's not he
looks like he's got makeup on to me I
don't know I'm no professional in makeup
I don't wear makeup I mean I just I
don't know anything about it so but to
me looks like he might
um have just had a wig on or something
he says I voted no on the era she goes
on to say I I was not going to help some
members in the U.S Senate an effect to
try to cheat to change our constitution
so he sees giving equal rights to women
in the Constitution with the 28th
Amendment known as the era are what
would be the 28th Amendment known as the
Equal Rights Amendment he sees that is
cheating
it's cheating to change our constitution
it's cheating when States ratify an
amendment
he's just upset
he's just upset that he changed the jet
deadline you changed the Constitution to
give women equal rights under the law
now some have said that this would
really affect the Roe v Wade decision
that could be correct
I'm Gonna Save this one for later
there's a there's a uh oh there's a
there's a there's someone on Facebook oh
man I'm Gonna Save this one for later
though because I I'm focused in on this
era
some folks say and surmise that the era
would change the landscape for Roe v
Wade folks the landscape is the
landscape is the landscape the legality
of it I guess maybe but these every
single one of these state legislators
every one of them are trying their
damnedest to take away rights from women
in particular their right to Health Care
and their right to their choices of
Health Care and their [__] privacy in
the doctor's office
it's big government inside your health
care in particular women and the reason
why is because just like Stephen Crowder
doesn't want he wants his wife to be
subservient they want all women to be
subservient that's what their obsession
with trans women is
they're not obsessed with trans men
they're not obsessed with that Jesus
Christ they're passing bathroom bills
and these states Kansas there's another
piece of [__] news Kansas bathroom
bill goes into effect
trans men who have beards
who look like me are gonna be walking
into women's restrooms and I actually
think I actually think there should be a
demonstration of trans men going to
Kansas and going into a woman's bathroom
as a cause for protest to show these
people what the [__] they're doing
they keep they can't stop face planting
it's ridiculous
they absolutely cannot focus on anything
else but someone else's genitalia
it's disgusting it's gross it's vile but
that's
what it is someone says appean that's
right that's what they should do they
should they should stage a protest
trans men should stage a protest in
Kansas [__] them show give them the
reality of what they're trying to do
it's it's not it's not about it's not
about
someone's genitalia because if it truly
was about trans people and not just the
hatred of a woman who looks sexy that
may have a wiener and confuse their
sexuality because that's what it's about
[__] you can say whatever you
want
this hatred of trans women comes from
the CIS white fragile men these
right-wing [__] fascists who are
terrified terrified if they could get a
woman to pay attention to them
who looks nice at a bar boy she's real
sexy and then they would have to maybe
just maybe find out that that sexy woman
that they're attracted to has a goddamn
penis it it kills their [__]
their world view it confuses them that's
what this is about so you damn right
there should be protest in Kansas where
trans men should go to Kansas stage a
protest and go in the woman's bathroom
because that's what is the law now
that's the [__] law show them what
they did
show them right out in the open show
them what they're doing show them how
their laws that they are passing make no
sense whatsoever
yeah
so enough of this stuff we have to fight
back we are going to beat the
pro-democracy Coalition is going to be
the only thing standing in the way
of fascism in this country that is it
and yes yes we have to take the [__]
gloves off
everyone gets mad at me sometimes for
saying that oh you can't say it like
that [__] I can't I will this is my
microphone I'll say it the way I want
and Democrats need to start getting
tough
set up for this [__] we don't have to
put up with this nonsense where they're
kicking a representative of Montana off
the floor
where she's duly elected and then and
then when she goes on a public bench
they're gonna try to ban her from a
public [__] because she's trans [__]
you it's enough of this stuff it's
enough we have to stand in the way of
fascism
thank you
because it's their their slow snowball
not not just with with
expelling two black men
in Tennessee expelling a trans woman in
Montana
Banning books in Florida
Banning math trying to get rid of Disney
in Florida
I'm telling you folks
2024 is the most important election of
our democracy's life
2022 was it's over we're now in the 2024
cycle and listen to me when I tell you
this that presidential race that is not
the most important race
that's not that's not the most important
one hell as a matter of fact with Donald
Trump being their nominee that one's
almost a goddamn slam dunk
it's the Senate it's the house it's the
state legislators
it we have to fight in these races
and we have to understand what they're
trying to do
and what they're trying to do is strip
away your Liberty
they're coming for it they're not just
it's not just about trans people it's
not just about women's health care
that's where they're starting it's not
just about the books or the education
Jesus Christ Oklahoma there's another
goddamn story they just don't stop it's
a waterfall of fascism
the Oklahoma house has voted to pass
vouchers one of the Reps sang out loud I
didn't have one constituent not one
constituent voiced their opinion to me
about making sure that I voted for
vouchers
and he still voted for it
it's clear what they want
it's clear the direction that they're
going
so what are we going to do huh what are
we going to do in our democracy I have a
special guest for you at the bottom of
the arm we're so close at the bottom of
the hour here
at crassenstein is Gonna Come On
he Ed may have Ed may have edited a
video of Tucker Carlson where Tucker
Carlson was saying one thing and another
thing and Elon quote tweeted him I'm not
kidding you Elon Musk
the head [__] over there at Twitter
quote tweeted Ed because he was really
upset that Ed took video of Tucker and
edited the way that Elon didn't want it
edited and thought it was all out of
context it's all it's all nonsense you
can't do this and put a community mark
on the video it's hilarious it's
hilarious that Elon is supposed to be
the beacon of freedom of speech
but people can't edit a video it's not
and I'm gonna I'm gonna clarify this
with it because I really want to fact
check this
I want a vac check to make sure that
this video is really Tucker Carlson both
Clips is really Tucker Carlson it's not
this new AI stuff which is all the buzz
as well so don't go anywhere don't go
anywhere
we'll be right back right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Maga
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon I was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the words that I'm struggling with I
chose Babel mag Edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now I can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new Mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
[Music]
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome welcome back to
the show
I'm sticking around through the break
got a special guest here with us in the
studio
and grab some teams joined us
I saw a tweet
from Elon Musk
I just couldn't help
but message Ed
about this um
this tweet
that um Elon had quote tweeted him on
I'm not kidding you Elon quote tweeted
Ed on a video that he made not it made
he just he just like clipped it together
you know we showed you the video of uh
Tucker Carlson's a little weird
and you know break of Silence
you remember this right and Ed took that
video and clipped it with another
interview that Tucker Carlson did where
he said
he was a liar and he liked he lied
and Elon didn't like that Ed are you are
you there I think it's hey it's there
yeah good can you see and hear me
because on my end I can't see myself I
can't I can't see you but I can hear you
very weird
um yeah so
I I had to correct a few things I could
I could I could I could see you before
wait you might have to set your you
might have to reset your reset your
camera there go in the settings give me
one minute yep
so I'm gonna I'm gonna make see if uh Ed
can get his camera going there
and I think I think it said it wasn't
connected with your lightning cord
that's what was showing on the screen
there and that might be the case
um he's gonna correct me on a few things
I I hope I hope I'm not white wrong here
um but there is a community notes let me
show you this uh tweet that um Elon Musk
while Ed's getting set up there
uh it says anyone making material false
statements on this platform will get
community noted ooh that sounds uh
sounds harsh including you and he means
Ed here me
Tucker advertisers head of state
Etc no exceptions
he's never gave me too many Community
notes I don't know maybe that means I I
I'm not the exception eh convince the
people and let the chips fall where they
may or a at Community notes this is the
community notes for the uh for the
Twitter page you can see now there's a
tag here
where it shows it's an official Twitter
account with the uh the gold check
now Ed posted this video here
now let me read you what what Ed wrote
he said I literally see hundreds of
tweets this morning saying things like
thanks Tucker or go Tucker
uh let me be clear about one thing
Tucker Carlson is an Entertainer he is
an Entertainer who stops down to levels
of bigotry and I think I think I think
um I think your camera's working now it
looks like you're good now
oh it it it it disconnected again I
think you got a faulty wire there he is
a liar who would tell people that they
wanted to hear just to get viewers and
better ratings
his expertise on Fox News was kissing up
to the audience's confirmation bias and
then spinning the narrative and
propagating lies and conspiracy to
entertain those biases check out the
video below here is the video now
Ed he's gonna probably correct me on a
few things here he said he was going to
but he Clips a few videos together but
you can see how Elon and Community notes
has added their Community notes here it
says reader added context the video is
edited and out of context
sources for the edited videos are here
to ensure viewers can ascertain the true
context of each of Tucker Carlson's
statements
and then of course you say do this find
this helpful Ed are you ready there can
you give me a thumbs up if you're ready
I think
I think you're struggling there now let
me let me can you give me a thumbs up if
you're ready
you ready all right Ed there you are
there you are how are you sir good how
are you oh man my green screen was
messing me up I'm sorry for that no
that's okay I know I know you're I I
tried to send you the video for the
green screen for stream yard but did
that was that helpful at least what it's
I set it up but when I come in the room
it doesn't show me for some reason so I
don't I don't know okay okay well maybe
maybe because you've been on the show
before maybe we'll have to fix this the
next time so any anyhow you are
partially right but you're also yeah hey
correct me correct me the video of
Tucker Carlson I basically took a few
things he was saying in the video that
he released and then I edited in every
few every few seconds I put in a segment
where he actually admitted to lying and
it wasn't taken out of context I well
because because this that where he's
admitting he's lying was not part of
Tucker's content right it was a podcast
that where he did an interview or
something yeah right separate interview
but he his ass but he was basically
asked do you ever lie and he said yeah I
lie
so he said I try not to lie on TV but I
lie and I put the part I said I lie so
they Community noted me is it is it out
of context I mean I think it was pretty
obvious that it wasn't part of the
context so it wasn't misleading because
they're two different videos I mean I
mean I guess it was out of context in
some way in that I separated but I mean
isn't every political ad you see out of
context right well that and that's kind
of the reason why I wanted to bring you
on because Elon pointed this out which
really so that's where I want to correct
you because Elon my point of view Elon
wasn't trying to be condescending to me
or try and attack me in any way it was
just other people were saying that I was
editing so you think Elon was coming to
your defense yeah so so Elon has
actually been engaging with Brian and I
quite a bit over the last well that's
interesting that's two weeks like
there's probably been like
maybe three retweets he's done of us and
probably like I don't know 15 or so
replies he's made our tweets he also has
followed us both and subscribed he pays
for us four dollars I noticed he's
engaging with you because he's been down
in your replies and stuff like you know
how Twitter has a new subscriptions if
you're yeah for the blue yeah she pays
both of us four dollars a month to be
subscribers to us and he's dm'd us as
well so so Elon wasn't trying to like
you know attack Us in any way oh okay
well hey that that's fair that's fair
enough he was just pointing out that you
know if people disagree with this tweet
they can use Community notes to check it
or you know put the facts out there as
they can with Tucker Carlson's tweets as
they can with my tweets so do you think
do you think in in that context though
of how Elon is responding to you and
your brother do you think that's
um a sign of him trying to do some
Outreach where he's he's really he's
really done a horrible job and um at
making sure that people know that he's
for freedom of speech and unbiased he
tried to paint that picture but he did a
very bad job of it when he originally
took over Twitter do you think this is
more of like an olive branch or reach
out to to the quote other side to try to
give some sort of I mean well I mean is
that is that part of this story I do in
a way I I think you know I think he did
a pretty bad job of
coming onto Twitter and pretending you
to not be biased I don't know if that
was his intention because it obviously
didn't seem that way but when you take
over a social media platform that was
criticized so much by the right for
being biased toward the left and you
want to make it neutral
it's probably not best for the CEO and
owner of the the new owner of the
company to be more right-leaning or at
least a pure more right-leaning on the
platform I I get it if he once you have
more conservative viewpoints good for
him and I and I think you know that's
his right and it's also his right to run
Twitter how he wants right if you want
to give a certain notion you have to
like I think he has he should be less
politically biased and I think maybe
he's he's realizing I don't know I mean
I don't want to guess what Elon thinks I
feel like he's like 35 steps me either
me either I I don't I don't want to know
what he is or isn't thinking about
either so so let me let me let me ask
you because I want to play this video of
Tucker Carlson but I want to make sure
that everyone
um knows your view of Tucker um before
we play this video because you're not
you're not trying to get at Tucker for
something that again they're saying it's
out of context and I I actually think
it's it's wrong it's not out of context
it's just your your video is cutting
away that they didn't appreciate because
he says he's a liar in the moments in
this video where he's saying the problem
is people are lying right like like his
video was trying to project that hey the
problem that we have is there's no more
true tellers and I'm a true teller and
then and then you send in the clip in
the moment where it's like I'm a liar
but I I guess I guess tell us what your
view is on Tucker Carlson leaving Fox
News or the firing of him or whatever
they want to call it this morning I
guess Megyn Kelly said that he wasn't
fired he's still under contract but who
gives a [__] what the semantics are
right like yeah they're making semantics
out of it now it's ridiculous it's
ridiculous but what if what what is your
view on Tucker's
um being being fired from Fox News and
then the video that he put out later on
in the week after three or four days of
Silence yeah I mean it's I think it's
pretty obvious that it was he was fired
whether you're going to get into the
semantics like you said was he let go
was he you know did they greet him
mutually have him leave I don't know but
Fox didn't want him there anymore I
think that's pretty apparent I you know
Tucker Carlson is an Entertainer he's
really really good at what he does
that's why his ratings are through the
roof that's why he makes like over 35
million dollars a year or was making
over 35 million a year he engages his
viewers he gets him involved in and to
me I think he does that by
taking creating narratives out of things
in order to fit them into like I'm
having all types of trouble with my
camera here literally we can still hear
you go ahead in order to fit things into
people's ideologies that they already
have you know like I I think I think he
likes creating these narratives in order
to get viewers and he does stuff in
order to get viewers you know Tucker
started out actually being somebody who
wanted to have unbiased news way back I
guess like back in I don't know 15 years
ago or so that's what his goal was and
he found out it wasn't working he found
out that his ratings sucked so he
gradually changed and became this person
who
I
I don't want to say he lies I mean I
think he definitely a lot has lied I
think he's definitely has misled the
public that's for sure but he creates
these narratives and he tells these
stories and he's he's such a good
Storyteller to make people feel like
what Democrats are doing or what certain
people are doing is really for a reason
that really isn't that reason like you
know like transgenderism is all about
pedophilia or you know like you like he
comes up with these narratives and gets
people to buy into them so I I think I
think Tucker's gone I think it's good
for Fox News in the long run for the
short in the short run I think it's
terrible because they're going to lose
ratings and I I think for the general
public it's good whether you realize it
or not I'm sure if you're Republican you
you probably love Tucker Carlson and
you're probably like you know it's
messed up that he's gone but I think
other stuff's going to come out from
from what I've read it appears as though
Fox News found some text messages I
found some private messages that were
that were redacted in the in the uh
Dominion lawsuit but they discovered
them right before the case before the
trial and that kind of led to the
settlement or played a role in the
settlement and also played a role in his
firing or letting him go or whatever you
want to say right I'm going to bring in
Gabe Sanchez before we play this um
video I'm going to play this um this
version that you had that you put out
that um the community notes now you say
Elon was kind of Defending you maybe I
saw it a different way maybe I saw it as
Elon um yeah I I wouldn't say he was
defending me he was just coming out and
saying you know if people disagree
Community note it and we'll get to the
bottom of this right right I personally
we'll find out if there's context or not
right is it well I I actually think that
Community notes is good
um it's just how it is used and when it
is used I think is the good or bad thing
but here's we'll let the audience decide
as Elon said here we'll let the chips
fall as they may here on the Tony
Michaels podcast for Ed's version of
Tucker's video when honest people say
what's true calmly and without
embarrassing they become powerful I mean
I lie at the same time the Liars have
been trying to silence them and shrimp
and they become weaker I just don't you
know I don't like lying I certainly do
it you know out of weakness or whatever
that's the iron law of the universe true
things prevail
where can you still find Americans say
true things there aren't many places
left but there are some and that's
enough as long as you can hear the words
I actually love Donald Trump as a guy
and
[Applause]
I
I know Trump I've known Trump for 20
years because I work in the media you
know
and I just have always gotten along with
them
laughs
passionately he hates Trump apparently
totally charming and engaging and fun
and interesting
I mean I lie
Ed I have to say I have to say um the
edit that you did there well it's pretty
good right it was pretty good and the
reason why is because and the reason why
I think they didn't like it and the
reason why he got pushed back is because
you use Tucker's own words in the spots
where they wouldn't want you to use
those words because the truth is is that
Tucker Carlson does lie and I know you
were trying to give him some leeway
there but he's a he's a liar he I mean
we we just want several lies right in
front of her I mean he admitted he
admitted to life that that video of him
saying I lie wasn't misleading anybody
he actually said when the SUV ever lies
so so I mean sure we all probably have
told a lie in our life so I guess you
know you could say oh it's misleading
because you're making it seem like he
lies all the time by putting it in I I
mean I don't know I think it's I mean
I'll go out on a limb and say that he
probably does lie a majority of the time
especially because In that clip he goes
look when I'm back into a corner I'll
lie to get out of it
and you know it's just like it's not I
didn't show that part exactly I could
have showed more that would even make it
look worse but right you could give it
more context which would make it worse
for Tucker and their their narrative now
I I want to ask you
um about the Nora Roberts because I
think you and your brother did you guys
write a piece this morning about the
book ban in Florida yeah I think Brian
did okay Brian wrote a piece and I think
he has a tweet about it so I I kind of
want to ask you about that but the other
thing I want to ask you about is a
couple of these clips
um
from I where the hell was this yesterday
where Donald Trump was he was acting
like
um he was in popular he was up he was
Northeast wasn't even like yeah or
something he was pretending to be
popular again uh in some other state
besides Florida
um and and not only
uh did he say some crazy [__] about Mike
Pence and
um how he and he's projecting here but
the one clip that everyone's talking
about and I'm not sure what the hell
he's doing speaking of context and or
not having gone dicks I don't know what
the hell he's doing in this clip but it
looks like he's he's [__] a diaper
but I think what he's doing is being
transphobic in this clip I think is the
actual context of it I'm not really sure
but I'll show the audience here and then
we'll see what Ed thinks of this little
moment and then we'll get to more
important moments because I think
there's some more important moments that
are more newsworthy but let's watch this
clip
uh
I'm gonna do it what
what
I I really am not like was he was he
trying to do like like a cleaning jerk
like what was he like thinking yeah so
here's the context I so I I actually
posted this video this morning and this
time I made sure to in my tweet to the
exact context so you didn't want to get
community noted this time is what you're
saying exactly okay so he was comparing
a woman lifting weights like a random
woman in a competition lifting weights
he said with an ounce on both sides of
the bar and he was doing a cleaning jerk
like you said that's crazy and then
comparing that to a transgender woman
competing against that woman and then
he's like up
but also like if you were if you were to
actually have him do that physical
activity I'm almost certain it would be
exactly like he did right there and then
he would also [__] his pants but yeah
yeah I mean at least many people are
saying that right what a lot of people
say a lot of people are saying now I
want to say that that moment is uh as
disgusting as the context is uh because
this is this is their new thing a lot of
these states even in my state of
Missouri uh the governor is considering
having a special session just on
transgender athletes in this in the
state of Missouri and I believe I
believe there's only three uh
transgender athletes that are under the
purview of Misha which is the State High
School Organization for sports right
that's what they call it here it's like
a percent of a percent right it's like
point zero right but it's like three
three youth athletes that they're gonna
have a special session they're gonna
call a special session which in this
and that just shows you how obsessed
they are with this issue because they
think this is going to work for them in
2024 I think that's kind of their
strategy here
um but I want to show you this is an
interview and I think this is the same
um fake little he's trying to fake that
he's popular thing
um in whatever state This was
um but this this clip here is an
interview and I'm not it's with a local
TV station there I think but he's
talking about Mike Pence and Mike Pence
testifying before the criminal grand
jury in Washington DC that has been
convened by the special counsel where he
lost his court case on the executive
privilege and Donald Trump also launched
that court case uh for executive let's
listen to his little ditty about uh Mike
Pence and maybe the fly on his head I
don't know I would like to be the blind
princesses but let's see reports this
afternoon that vice president fence
testified before a grand jury regarding
what happened between November 2020 and
January 21 worried at all about what you
might say no I'm not wearing it at all I
wish you would have sent it back to the
legislators if you did that I think he
would have had a different result
obviously he had the right to do it
because they changed the law right after
the election
and it turned out they did have a choice
because that's why they changed the law
no that's a line I just want Mike to be
truthful we had a very good relationship
during my time together also a lot he
does not want Mike Pence to be truthful
that's um for sure that's why he filed
the the code well that's what they
always say right they're always like you
got to speak you got to speak the truth
we got a First Amendment we gotta say
Our Truth we gotta speak it so that the
American people know exactly what's
going on but when you do in an example
like Ed's case right you actually show
the truth and people go oh no no no this
is all fabricated and that
explosion
or just his own words man they're just
rake stepping they're just they're
they're it's and it's continually face
planning and if you're still there with
your audio what did you make of that
clip yeah I I mean it's ridiculous he he
knows that I'm just getting my camera
back up here he knows that if Mike Pence
testifies honestly it's not going to do
anything to help him you know that it
definitely won't help him if Mike Pence
has some bad things you say or if he
does recall instead of saying I don't
recall it's probably not going to be
good for Trump right well and I I think
that was the whole Court battle and I
think Mike Pence when he filed for um
not just the executive privilege but he
also filed for the speech in Bay clause
and he won the speech and debate clause
but that's from gavel the gavel of when
he can actually invoke that privilege
um which Trump should have just went
with that which um I I was surprised
that Trump tried to still take it to
court because it only projects
more of what guilty would have right
because he doesn't want Mike Pence to go
in and speak on this issue even though
he would have the speech and debate
clause and that privilege uh guaranteed
in that testimony for the grand jury he
could invoke that privilege if he wanted
to
um the courts gave him that privilege
um through that lawsuit which I was
actually surprised by that decision and
I was surprised that they wanted to
further this ladder up the up the legal
ladder which could have taken that
privilege away from Mike Pence um
there's one other
um clip I believe I want to show if I
can find it here of this
um it's talking about
um
uh January 6 and he says something in
particular that I want to show you here
listen to what he says about January 6
and whose fault it is not listen to this
I talked to a lot of those voters a lot
of them are still upset about what
happened on January 6 2012
to what extent can you provide
assurances did something like that is
well it wasn't my fault and this was a
lot of people that thought the election
was rigged and stolen A lot of people
I still feel that as you know you saw
the audience tonight this was a packed
house you could have sold it out four
times so I I'm not sure how packed the
house was in his uh his fake it probably
was like if I were to go on to rumble
right now and look at the live stream I
feel like I would find a very
underperforming audience
uh but also I mean that's also when he
says like oh it's not my fault like
that's totally like during coven he's
like not my responsibility right like
wrong this is you know it's it's how he
works right he doesn't take
responsibility when things go wrong he's
not I mean it's you're not gonna have
that happen yeah well I mean yeah hell
would freeze over in the day that he
decides to say yep that was my fault
well but the other thing that I think is
significant is he says it's not my fault
but then he capitulates to the January 6
insurrectionist when he's saying a lot
of people were mad about the rigged and
stolen election why were they mad why
why were they mad what could possibly
have drove them what lies could have
drove them to be mad about a rigged and
stone election that actually wasn't
rigged and stolen and as a matter of
fact did I think we're finding out more
that we see from Georgia and I think
um funny Willis is going to be the next
step in indictments for Trump I think
Jack Smith is taking his sweet time to
make sure he builds the best case he
possibly can against him
um I think I think that's Jack Smith's
aim all indications are is that they're
um his Target is Trump here but finally
Willis's case if I think we're going to
find out in Georgia in that case that
hey it was trying to be rigged and
stolen not by democrats by Donald Trump
and the Republicans um what do you what
do you make of this idea that he says
it's not my fault a lot of people
thought the election was rigged and
stolen and the possibility of us finding
out that yes it was trying to be rigged
and stolen from Donald Trump himself
yeah well of course he's going to say
that because he's under investigation
and different two different
jurisdictions for you know being behind
that or having being involved in it so
of course he's not going to say oh yeah
it was rigged and stolen and it's
because I said it was you know I I think
the Georgia investigation I think that
that could be really bad for Trump I you
know the New York one and it wasn't
really that much to really worry about I
don't think for him
I think you know he might end up getting
a slap on the wrist but I don't see him
going to jail for a long time prison for
a long time for that uh Georgia I don't
know I mean if it's a if it's a RICO
case if it's you know a large conspiracy
it it could get bad and there's I mean
there's audio recordings of him talking
to the Secretary of State and talking to
lawmakers and I think there's even
recordings we haven't heard yet so so it
could get bad for Trump and
I would be worried about that and I'm
pretty sure he probably is well here's
here's another
um clip of him from this event where
he's talking about
it's Russia with this guy always always
this yeah Russia Russia collusion
collusion collusion that's what he likes
to say and speaking of community notes
uh and context here I wanna I wanna tell
you he's gonna try to quote Lenin but I
believe he's thinking of Stalin and he's
quoting it wrong he gets the quote wrong
it's not actually the quote but
I had to look this up this morning to
find this out because I know that he he
doesn't know what he's talking about the
majority of the time so I figured he
didn't know what he's talking about with
this quote because he says this quote
all the time because he likes it and I
think it's because he's like I wish I
would have thought of that before 2020
uh myself but but listen listen here and
see if you can catch the projection you
know Lenin
Lenin did anyone ever hear of blood in
who said the vote counter is far more
important than the candidate has anyone
ever heard that's Lenin Lenin as they
say
I think that's what Putin says to him
that's literally I think that's Putin
has probably corrected him in real time
no no it's linen Oh I thought you meant
that that quote is what Putin says no
well I mean I mean it is Russia it is
Russia so I mean what are you gonna you
know I because in Russia it is who's
counting the votes who matters
um and I mean it isn't the candidate
because Putin has always won because of
that fact and speaking of that um
morning so I I just I just had to look
this up yeah because I was curious right
and so there you know the question it is
a Stalin quote right hold on this the
claim is that Joseph Stalin said some
version of it's not the people who count
the vote it's the people who uh sorry
it's not the people who vote that count
it's the people who count the votes okay
that's what the claim is now there's a
mixture of it being a true false and the
origin seems to be
a medley of people throughout history
who have said this thing so
it seems to be misappropriated and it
says okay so in 1923 by Stalin
referenced it a quote by the Central
Committee and the Communist Communist
Party of Soviet Union I consider a
completely unimportant who in the party
will Vote or how but what is
extraordinarily important is this who
will count the votes and how so it seems
to be a mix of that's not the direct
quote that he had it's a different
version of the quote but there have been
other people throughout history who have
said something similar to that extent so
it's Stalin kind of if we'll say it like
that kinda yeah what do you think of it
what do you think even though like it's
yeah I don't know what do you make of it
I mean this weird thing no Ed what do
you make of him saying I mean it's just
it's just jumping Trump I think you know
it's him putting this stuff out there
just to kind of support his narrative
and support what his base believe
happened it's kind of like saying yeah
the election was rigged but I'm not
saying the election was rigged right
right well but don't don't you don't you
believe that because we've we've gone
over the the uh hostage type videos that
he does from Mar-A-Lago here on this
show several times and really when he
first started doing them uh me and Gabe
were giving him tips right because I
think Liz Harrington actually watches
our show because every time we give him
tips on like lighting and camera angles
and how they should cut like the next
week those videos they were following so
I know Liz you're doing a bang-up job
listening to how you're you know editing
those hostage Style videos
um but when he does these videos
Liz next time you should put Trump in an
orange jumpsuit oh there you go there
you go you think that I actually think
that would help like it would definitely
brighten up right the uh yeah why yeah
I'm not just talking about the lighting
in the in the yeah yeah in the capture
I'm talking about it would help with his
base because oh yeah it only seems to
solidify his face criminal you know
right just play that play that I'm a
victim kind of thing
speaking of his tiny hands uh that is
one thing that we learned uh this week
um in in the E Gene Carroll trial uh
where she described what Donald Trump
had had did to her uh to rape her in a
department store and that is another
legal Jeopardy that this buffoon is in
it's not criminal it is civil
um but him not appearing
at this trial Ed do you think that's
that's also significant
um I mean I I feel that it is because
he's publicly he's publicly posting
about it and not appearing at the trial
if he was being quiet which he's not
capable of doing I don't think uh I
think it might have a different effect
but it really he they face plant every
time he's a professional rake stepper um
yeah what do you make of that trial
because there's that one going I don't I
didn't really expect him to show up it's
not a criminal trial it's a civil trials
and he doesn't really show up to any of
his civil trials or any of his
businesses I think he's just like oh
it's just you know it's not I'm not
going to go to prison over this why
should I be there I'm not going to
testify it's just going to make more of
a spectacle out of if I am there you
know it's just going to give writers
more to write about me and write about
the trial so why go and I mean I guess
we'll see how it turns out I I still
don't know like I don't know how this
trial is going to turn out they got from
what I'm reading you know the defense
has made some good points uh it's just
hard to like not being there not hearing
everything it's hard to see where it's
going to go so what are you wait and see
right right and I but what do you make
of uh the story that uh EG the the
transcripts from the e Gene Carroll
story uh what do you make what do you
make of that I mean I mean I believe her
you know I believe her story but
it's not up to me and I haven't seen all
the evidence I haven't heard all the
testimony so I I really can't make that
judgment I'm going to trust the jury you
know I think
there it is you know you're so measured
Ed you're so measured
it's almost like you don't want
Community notes or something yeah well
nobody can Community note this right you
know hell no hell no they can't they
can't Community note this uh Ed you've
always been a favorite um when we're in
you and your brother Brian uh when we're
in when me and Gaber in the Twitter
spaces of Marios and um um so I've
enjoyed being in those spaces with you
and this is the second time you've been
on the show
um and I hope you uh come back and I
hope we get your green screen camera
thing maybe we'll take an afternoon to
to figure that out so that way when you
come in the studio we're good to go so I
could just move and use my phone so
there's actually instead of having an
empty wall behind me no no it's fine
it's fine it looks it looks perfect hey
you know what we're we're here for your
opinion not exactly for your background
anyway so uh Ed I appreciate everyone go
follow Ed and his brother Brian on
Twitter and all the social media
platforms you guys got a sub stack too
correct yeah we do we've actually been
focusing more on the two Twitter
subscription stuff like trying to
provide more content for our subscribers
on there than the sub Stacks so okay hey
go ahead do a Shameless pitch thing do a
Shameless pitch right I mean that's all
I got that's all you got it's just the
Twitter okay everyone go follow Ed and
his brother Brian on Twitter and and
make sure to stop by um when they are me
and Gabe are in those uh Twitter spaces
because sometimes we're the only voices
of like
logic and rationale I mean it just it's
it's um it's incredible sometimes in
those spaces what you're hearing and
listening to uh but we try to we try to
be there to push back and and I actually
appreciate that Mario has Us in those
spaces to try to push back on the quote
other side
um wise is what I mean by that by other
side
um but uh Ed it's it's great to see you
any final thoughts that you have before
we leave
uh no I mean I think just I I think it's
important you know a lot of people are
discouraged about Twitter especially on
the left I think it's important to
remain on there because without the
left's voices the rights just gonna take
over and they're gonna get their message
out to so many more people so I I think
you know the whole blue check thing a
little discouraging for people on the
left uh I just don't get too discouraged
you know keep keep getting the word out
maybe you don't want to post as often as
you normally do but I think it's
important to keep giving your opinion on
things I think that's really important
well I appreciate you being on the show
and I appreciate you sticking in there
on Twitter because I I feel the same way
we can't leave these platforms and leave
them uh to the lines in the right wing
and let it spread like crazy we've got
to be there to check them uh at all
costs because our democracy depends on
it Ed crassenstein thank you for joining
us everyone stick around we're going to
be back with the week right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
well
Ed had some camera problems Gabe has
been having this microphone problem
there he is he's back again I was not
sure if he's gonna make it back in the
studio now
he says one minute he says one minute
okay and we're at the top of the hour
we're gonna do bonehead of the week as
soon as uh Gabe gets reset here uh I am
loading in the graphics for bonehead of
the week I I think uh you're gonna like
bonehead of the week this week
um because we have some real boneheads
but we want to go through this and and
we've already been talking about one of
the boneheads but there is a story out
there that I want to get to
of a right winger who
um is always transphobic
and he continues to say vile [__] on his
show about
the transgender community and gender
reassignment surgery and apparently uh
he's had gender
reconfirming surgery of his own Gabe
Sanchez are you are you good over there
is it really good yeah I had to reset I
would I don't know there might be a
delay I gotta
I think I might need a new computer man
I'm running this thing down to the show
[__] editing for what was that man
this computer is finally like I think
taken up did it take a [__] I think if
Donald Trump the bed hey Donald Trump
the bed I think that's what's happening
in the song at some point in the near
future I'm gonna have to buy a a new
computer to replace this uh I see this
Dying Breed over here I really thought
that um I really thought that Donald
Trump [__] his diaper and then yeah I
said I last night or yesterday I tweeted
I said many people are saying that Trump
[__] himself after while doing this I'm
surprised someone didn't put a fart
noise in one of the edits to be quite
honest it got a lot of views though like
just that one little clip and it's a
shame that it was out of context
um you know it's kind of like the Rhonda
Santos moment you know um yeah you take
it out of context man did you did you
hear uh Rhonda santis really stepped in
it yesterday when a reporter asked him a
question he got really pissed off
because
because she's a little [__] ass [__]
yes they're all [__] ass [__] here's
the thing at the end of the day these
people can't take criticism they can't
handle it and Ron DeSantis is a perfect
example look if they were to if you were
to put two people against each other who
could actually like defend themselves
in in an actual like argument it's gonna
be Trump over Ron DeSantis like I'm not
saying he's a good person to debate or
or like you know have an argument
against but he is very you know he's
[__] childish and he he's like I'm
not that's not what I you know it's like
I'm rubber your glue you know like
whatever bounce off me sticks to you
like uh well you know it's just it's
that it's that childish behavior and
that's what Trump unfortunately is good
at where he's like huh uh you know and
then he says like some dumb [__]
insult about smiles not my fault I
didn't I didn't break the lamp I mean
that's what it seems like hey I got an
update for you on Twitter on Twitch moly
so yesterday we we're gonna try to see
if we can get the Thousand we're at
993 subs or followers wow we're almost
at a hundred we're at 99
subscribers for prime
so that means if people who have Prime
accounts Amazon Prime accounts have
linked it to their Twitch account and
gave us that one free subscription we're
almost at 100 we're almost at a thousand
followers so seven people that's all we
need is seven people and there's been
that let's see here now last hour one
two three
four four Amazon Prime
subscription so I want to thank you all
from yesterday and today for getting us
so close to a thousand we're we're only
seven away so if you're out there in the
audience whatever platform you're on and
you have a Twitch account or you want to
open a Twitch account do it now go
follow us we need seven more people to
reach a thousand and I really appreciate
it we have the best audience in the
world here and if you want to link your
Amazon Prime account to your Twitch
account
well here's what happens you can give us
that one free subscription that you get
with Amazon Prime it doesn't cost you a
single penny more than what you're
already spending for prime
the show gets again it's like a couple
bucks it's two or three bucks we
actually get five
do do we have a way for people to to
follow to easily follow along for them
to link up their Prime to their Twitch
account you mean like a video
video or is there like a photo kind of
like she's like oh here's step one step
two step three because I'm sure like a
lot of people in here might be like yeah
I'm a prime twitch user but so there are
videos there are videos on YouTube if
you want you can go to YouTube search in
um link Amazon Prime to Twitch and then
you can put that search link into the
chat if you want
um that way people can go find several
videos because also
um a video
the other thing too is to have
um a video of re-subscribing because not
only do you have to tie your which
account to there we're at nine because I
wouldn't be surprised if there were
people in the chat you know and I you
know if I were to look through right now
I'm I wouldn't be surprised if there are
people in the chat who are like I'd love
to but
I don't know how to it's not it's not
hard to link it um some some people are
saying that they don't have Prime and
you don't have to have Prime to follow
us over there on Twitch you can follow
us on Twitch it doesn't cost a single
thing to follow the follow is free
um and so is linking your Amazon Prime
account but you don't have to have a
Prime account to follow us so and we're
at 9.96 now we just got another
subscriber on Prime this is like
real-time stuff wait man supporters
[Music]
the week to do here
someone says do it on your phone it's
way easier yes I think it is really easy
on your phone because if you have the
Twitch app and the prime app it works
really easy that way or you can do it on
the computer
um so
um and and that's coming from a twitch
viewer and that's the other thing you
can do if you want to go to Twitch and
follow us on Twitch you can talk to the
twitch the twitch folks in the chat a
lot of people that are in the channel or
on Twitch are very familiar with twitch
they're probably more familiar with
twitch than I am I I actually have no
idea I I originally thought honestly
Gabe is like a gaming thing
I mean and it is primarily well right
right but now there's a lot of podcast
shows and yeah
um hot tub streams if you're into that
sort of thing I mean there's a lot of
stuff on Twitch there's a lot of weird
[__] they even have you know you were
doing the ASMR yesterday on your
microphone yeah
yeah they have they're people that do
ASMR microphones and they have people
who I I I'm not kidding you because when
I now I don't go watch this maybe
um but when I was originally trying to
figure out what we should do on Twitch
and if we should put the show on Twitch
I would watch what the hell was on
Twitch and there's people who
they lick microphones on Twitch I'm not
kidding you this is a thing
um so don't don't don't lick your
microphone to please
please refrain from licking all right
fine crying out loud Jesus Christ jeez I
mean don't put a I mean don't don't
offer me a good time man yeah to the
twitch to the twitch Chatters out there
to the twitch chat do they still do hot
tub streams on what the [__] is a hot
tub stream okay so someone sets up like
do I need to invest in a hot tub
I mean you may want to you could
probably you could probably get a lot
you dress up in a um in a thong or a
thong bikini and you get in a hot tub
and you stream uh yourself listen to
music and talking to the um
the audience in a hot tub you know
that's so well I don't know if my
landlord would like me putting a hot tub
in the apartment well I think it's like
an inflatable one it's not like a yeah
that's even worse though that sounds
anymore like that's even more like
there's uh air that holds water in and I
feel like at any moment
that thing could just pop and then I've
got it's like it's like oh why people
don't get Waterbeds anymore because it's
a [__] liability right right like
right did you ever have a waterbed
uh we had a water bed when I was a kid
yeah
um and I remember it was in it was in
the basement it was in the guest room
and so it was just like a room whenever
like family or someone would come by and
it was a water bed
I just remember getting in trouble when
I would jump on the waterbed and my dad
and my mom would be like you're gonna
pop it do that you're gonna pop this
thing and yeah so we had one we had
Waterbeds when I was a little kid like
in the [__] late 80s early 90s yeah
it was all the rage man I mean 70s 70s
it was a big thing like there was the if
anyone seen um licorice pizza
the movie in that movie uh the the kid
in there is trying to sell you know he
gets into like how do I make money and
one of the schemes that he does is
selling water beds but during the oil
crisis he couldn't because oil was used
to create you know to create the the
material of the waterbed so they
eventually had to go under and then he
had to find a new thing to sell but I
remember that specifically uh as a plot
point in the movie if anyone had seen
that uh movie
um so just in the last few minutes here
we went to 102 subscribers and we're at
999 followers wow doing a B on Thousand
if you want to be the thousands follower
I'll give you a shout out here I'll be
I'll be uh checking it out and watching
it here I'll watch the the tallies here
99. you are the best audience in the
world we should really start bonehead of
the week shouldn't we you know what 999
is what's 999 666 upside down
leave it at 999 then
should we or should we just go for I
don't know if you can leave it right
you're someone's gonna someone's Gonna
Wanna Be that one thousand right person
winner you know or there could be a
glitch it could go down 998 yeah I mean
there's those moments where like you're
like oh look where I'm at I'm like
teetering on this thing and then
someone's like unfollow follow unfollow
follow unfollowable just to [__] with
you just to mess with you ah there's the
thousands follower right now Tech no
lawyer one techno lawyer one one who is
our is our I'm going to follow you on
Twitch yesterday you're a thousand boom
you're followed whether you like it or
not
people said people said I'm out of sync
I know I'm out of sync I was I was in
sync earlier it's my I'm telling you
it's my [__] computer man I was good
for a while and I couldn't Ed was having
trouble with this camera when I brought
him on and I think it was I don't know
was it timed or something it seemed like
I don't ever looked like the USB it just
kept giving the USB connection but I
think with mine like I've run this
computer down
with all of the like the graphics that
we do for the show uh the editing the
all of them yeah yeah blame it on the
show would you I'm just saying man like
I do it I you know I do I make all the
graphics for the bonehead segments and
stuff and then I've got you know the
what was that and so that's what I'm
saying I feel like
you know in the in the two-year no well
less than two years a year and a half or
so that we've been doing this really
[__] dropped this thing man you know
so I got I don't know I gotta I gotta
figure it out we'll we'll see what's
happening some people are asking if
they're uh if theirs went through I I
don't know uh specifically it doesn't
it's kind of hard to tell it tells me
who subscribes and who re-subscribes but
it feels like the subscriptions with the
prime is a little delayed
um the files are almost immediate over
here
um but it looks like it might be because
it's a processing maybe right well
because when you link your Prime and
your in your Twitch it it um it takes a
minute or two but when you follow it's
almost instantaneous so we're at a
thousand three followers right now let
me see if I can refresh see if I can get
that
fun fact Gabe is out of sync in real
life is it really is that how is that
how it works that's probably why we
never met in real life everyone always
asks that they're like
in real life right I've always I've
always assumed that you were AI to be
I'm not saying I'm not oh okay well uh
oh which reminds me yeah I do have uh
I'm gonna come up with a new segment for
what was that okay
um so it involves AI in chat yeah yeah
so okay uh people who are on my patreon
I I gave you guys a heads up I'm well
I'll be talking about it I'll probably
like
iron out the details with you guys while
I'm while I'm doing the weekend Roundup
but I had this idea over the last couple
days and I was like ah maybe this maybe
I could do something with this so I'm
gonna be experimenting with chat gbt
with what was that well go to
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez uh to find
out what the chat GPT new segments going
to be also why you're on patreon.com
visit my page the Tony Michaels just
type in the Tony Michaels at patreon.com
the Tony Michaels and we're gonna we're
gonna do ask me anything
um right after the show so while I'm at
now I'm gonna have to take a break
to like take a piss will you stop
Whispering into the goddamn microphone
you're making the audience horny for
crying out loud it's freaking Jesus
they're all gonna leave here and go to
Pornhub and have to I mean it sounds
like I need to get a hot tub I think so
I think you need to get a hot tub and uh
an ASMR uh microphone that way you could
you can stream over on yeah maybe I
should do maybe I should have uh should
I do like my own channel or I should do
like an only fans but you can it's only
just do it on our Channel it doesn't
matter to me you can put your own
channel I don't give a [__] I don't care
I don't care what's on our Channel I
don't over on Twitch I don't honestly
again when I first I tried to figure out
what twitch was I went and grabbed the
handle right because that's what you're
supposed to do when you got yeah you
grabbed the handle you know really grab
it by the handle grab it by the handle
but anyway so I went and got my handle
you [__] on Twitch the Tony Michaels
right and I had it for a while but I
didn't know what twitch was like I was
like oh this is gaming but I'm gonna go
grab it because it's right you know a
huge platform I want to have the handle
on the platform yeah you wanted that
that nice yeah big handle you know Jesus
Christ what I mean you're the one who
has the dick shadow in the background oh
that's true a lot of people it's right
up here some people think that looks
like a dick I don't think it looks like
a dick this is gonna be this is like the
Streisand Effect where it's like you
don't want people to talk about it but
now people are gonna talk about it
because you tell people you have to talk
about it there it is I mean look at that
look at that I mean
it looks like there's also a little I
mean also is that what is that Shrubbery
Bush going on yeah that's that's well
that's the pubic hairs right that's what
I that's what I'm thinking I mean like
that's what it looks like right it's
actually the Shadow from the megaphone
yeah is it though
I mean you tell me I don't know I don't
know someday someday we'll get a
close-up
okay so I got my handle right I had it
for months and then um someone said on
the show uh hey you should stream to
Twitch I watch on Twitch I'm like what
the [__] I didn't know you could do that
so I go try to investigate it and I'm
like oh yeah I can I can do that pretty
easy I can stream to Twitch and that's
actually how the shitless Roundup was
born I was like hey this twitch thing
ain't so bad maybe I should try to you
know stream every once in a while so I
do it like three or four days a week I
would stream for like 30 minutes or an
hour where I'd surf Twitter that's where
the shitless Roundup came from that's
where it came from and that so then so
what happened was is me and Gabe we met
on Twitter I know he was sending me he
was sending me dick pics in the DM and I
was like all right he's like listening
all right so and I said
so so he actually I invited him on the
show and we talked about satire and
parody at the time uh it's actually
episode
47 36 43 43 I don't know 43 or 46. it's
one of those so if you want to go watch
the episode where Gabe was the guest the
first time he's ever on the Tony
Michaels podcast it's like 43 or 46 I'm
some [__] like that anyways go look it
up on the YouTube channel it's there but
anyways that's what that's right Robin
says 43 okay 43. so it's episode 43 and
you can listen to it on Apple Spotify
and Google so don't forget to go
download it uh if you want to listen to
it but here's the thing
so I then had Gabe be our co-host and
executive producer he came on board and
we combined the show which is the a
block which is the 30-minute rant that
you guys know and love and then the [__]
list Roundup where we round up all the
sweeties weeds and transons and then
this segment the bonehead of the week so
let's get to it let's do bonehead of the
week
[Music]
[Applause]
of the week your Edition here on YouTube
twitch twitch we got there's uh Jesus
Christ it's a hundred
108 subscribers now on Prime God damn
you guys
a thousand and four followers you guys
are awesome amazing amazing thank you
thank you very much it's so easy I think
I think why it's becoming so popular on
the show here is because it's so easy if
you have a Prime account it doesn't cost
you any extra to give us that monetary
support by using it but you do have to
you do have to renew it every month
that's kind of the pain in the ass but
it takes like three seconds
um on your app if you have both apps the
Twitch app and maybe maybe what we
should do is you know we should make a
video and then we throw it in as like a
commercial break there's a couple of
there's a couple moderators that um that
keep saying that so let's let's make the
video and it sounds like a good idea
like if they also thought of it too like
I'm just thinking like hey and it like
literally it only it only takes a few
seconds to show the video then we'll
just show it during the show so you can
see it um and really honestly if you
want to uh everyone over there on the
twitch channel in the chat there's a lot
of them that will know how to link it
because they they've done that and
they're they're in there so you go
follow on Twitch it doesn't cost
anything to follow and you don't have to
link your Prime account to follow we
just get money if you link it and give
us the subscription because there's a
difference on Twitch between following
and subscribing it's [__] confusing
because YouTube you subscribe and that's
how you follow it's got your own word
man
I think YouTube is considering changing
it though did you know that they're
changing well they're changing well
because you can subscribe on YouTube if
you're monetized which I'm not because
I'm a foul mouth
um at this point I've been trying to get
it back but they won't chat with that
they so they want to change it to what
follow And subscribe like Twitches so so
you won't say subscribe on YouTube
you'll say follow on YouTube and then
you can give us subscription right but
there's some men they won't say then
they'll change it from join to subscribe
because right now I think it says join
is that what it says on I think it says
it used to say subscribe so now it says
join yeah join like if you have like a
if you have a uh a membership a
membership yeah yeah I think I think
they're gonna change or they're
considering changing anyways the point
is this on Twitch it doesn't cost
anything to follow
unsubscribe you can link your Prime
account to the twitch count and it's
free to subscribe if you don't have a
Prime account you can subscribe for five
bucks you can't do that and I was trying
to explain this the other day because
someone on Twitch was asking this like
how much money we get of the
subscription and it's not the full five
dollars because then bastards charge you
that's how they make money they take
part of your money for that subscription
that's why the prime thing is so cool
because [__] it it's Amazon's money who
cares it's [__] Amazon's money so
they'll so twitch gets and Amazon owns
twitch if you didn't know then Amazon
[__] owns it so it's really like they
stick take it out of one of their
pockets and put it in the other one of
their pockets you know what I mean yeah
yeah somebody said this looks like oh I
know what it is it's my chair it's my
chair okay you've got a dick Shadow too
look look in the bottom left corner
somebody pointed out there's uh uh
Brendan said oh well now you can't sorry
oh my bad okay hold on hold on
I gotta take it down you got to take the
other one down too okay hang on hang on
there we go okay it's a it's a slice it
looks like a nipple Shadow not really
addiction hold on let me see it depends
on where my chair is see it looks like
it looks like it's very you got to be
very careful that's not a dick though oh
well you know hey look Tony no judgment
no judgment that's addiction look man
everyone's made differently everyone's
unique I know look you know sometimes
it's all about the lighting in the
shadow it is it is we get the bonehead
Jesus Christ what are we doing okay
here's our boneheads Tucker Carlson Elon
Musk and Mike Pence why did we put Elon
let's start there why did we put Elon on
this list I think you said Elon I I went
with Mike Pence of course Tucker was a
given yeah yeah I put Elon because uh
well there was the rocket that exploded
but there was new details about that and
then there was another wow what was the
other one no I mean there could be a
million reasons why Elon was was on this
list but the I mean this was like I'll
think about it this was last night
yeah I know a lot happens oh oh now I
know he went to [__] to Schumer is that
what it was yeah it might have been nice
yeah yeah so Elon Elon um you know we
were talking about Elon earlier with Ed
because Elon Elon has been um
interacting with the Cranston steam
Brothers Christ's team Brothers right oh
no the other one was uh well you could
do that as well it was his [__] uh
his alt account
because Elon had opened an ALT account
so he could reply to himself and like
his own stuff but yeah so Elon has an
ALT account where he PL he he goes under
the identity of his kid the the one with
the X
the one that sounds like that uh it's
like
x83
I don't know he calls him [__]
whatever dude it's a [__] weird name
[__] yeah yeah you know people pop up
you know it's [__] like that
um he gave his kid that name which
obviously it's like as a parent man you
just set that kid up for like a ton of
[__] jokes against them but whatever
um
so he he he made a an ALT account that
he was using to say
weird [__] like he was commenting as a
person who's like I'm gonna be three in
May right on May 4th or whatever May 5th
I'm gonna be three years old and then
would go and comment and be like how old
are you are you going to the club
tonight like [__] weird [__] he was
liking comments and replies and stuff
yeah yeah yeah so and the reason what
happened was because it there was a
screenshot that was taken that showed
hey look this is how many subscribers
that Elon Musk has on uh on Twitter and
in there you could see there was another
profile photo
and it was his kid with like this silver
Little Rocket toy and when you look at
the account and then you I did a reverse
image search and looked around and found
that there are only three three
references to that exact photo it was a
person who was using that photo to show
that it was Elon Musk another one was
doing it to say it was something about
um
some like Tesla like Dogecoin kind of
thing and then the other one was the
account itself so it's it's him it's
weird it's [__]
kind of creepy gross you know the idea
that he would pretend to be uh two about
to be three-year-old kid and then say
some potentially sexually inappropriate
things to someone who's an adult online
but it's all him it's all Elon being
like Oh you know and it's an ALT account
that he's getting and it's obvious it's
because there was a screenshot that he
put out that gave it away uh Paulie here
on Twitch says we made a level one train
and apparently it's been um the hype
train on Twitch I don't I don't know
what this is I don't know it's a hype
train not not like that kind of train
game I see your mind wandering it's a
nice dream it's a height hype train on
Twitch it's reached level two
um whatever that means maybe I I'm gonna
get an education twitch here yeah I got
to eventually maybe you should talk to
your your kids and be like educate me
listen my son I actually tried to ask
him what twitch was when I was invest
investigating it and then I had to go to
it and see the hot tub uh stream yeah
you had to go see the hot yesterday
I was trying to figure it out okay I was
trying to figure it out but my son's
like no I don't watch Twitch I watched
the the um um the videos on YouTube the
bods he calls them bods video on demand
v-o-d oh by the way I want to give
people an update on the emotes uh I
can't do it because I'm not an admin on
the Twitch account I sent it I sent it
so this is all my fault it is actually I
sent it to Tony and I said I can't do
this you have to do it because you're
the admin okay so I just want to give
people update I sent to this like a week
and a half ago to Tony I sent him the
link on how to do it I'm such a lazy
bastard listen no just know that it's
not me okay listen listen listen I will
at all the twitch users now that we have
um a hundred and our thousand and five
followers over there and 110 uh Prime
subscribers what we were trying to do is
we were trying to get the emotes and
I'll try trying to figure that out
whatever the hell that means
razor razor B for our razor Beast I
think is what it is just subscribe for
two months this is the second month you
re-subscribe and so don't forget to
re-subscribe over on Twitch you have to
do that now someone else is saying hype
train I'm not sure what the hype what is
that what the [__] is that is that just
because we reach so many people
subscribing and subbing is that what it
is did we unlock it was level one like
under a thousand and then level two is
over a thousand I guess so [__] I don't
know like is this like is this is this
like a digital Soul Train we're running
the train they're running a train on me
Gabe I don't know okay let's get back to
business here all right
um let's go to Mike Pence why was Mike
Pence on the list Mike I think I put
Mike Pence yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I was I was out I was out uh
running some errands and then I saw that
I saw that breaking news alert that was
like Mike Pence just testified before a
grand jury seven
he said
I plead the fifth
um I actually don't think that Mike
Pence would probably plead the fifth
much in there you know well because I
think the criminality goes to Donald
Trump that's why that's why Mike Pence
is the actual one testifying in front of
the grand jury not not
um Donald Trump yeah you gotta remember
criminal grand juries are generally not
going to bring in the Target to question
them like until the very end if if they
do it all if you remember back um The
Manhattan DA's uh when they were had the
grand jury they invited Donald Trump but
because he already knew they were
investigating him and what and and a lot
of that evidence was out in the open
because of the trial that they just had
with the Trump organization so they they
I don't think uh Alvin Bragg that
Manhattan D.A saw it as a detriment to
his case if Donald Trump would have came
in and testified in front of the grand
jury probably would have seen it as an
asset to his case but in the criminal
grand jury in D received for the special
counsel Jack Smith I would imagine that
Donald Trump won't even be offered the
opportunity to come sit in front of the
grand jury until the very end
um but the idea that
uh other these other people are
testifying in front of the grand jury
indicates that they're not the target
that's what it would indicate it doesn't
mean that they can't can't be a Target
so they might invoke the Fifth Amendment
if their lawyers like hey fifth you know
don't do don't say that [__] that's
self-income I mean it also doesn't it
doesn't help that uh you know those 90
plus what
well what we learned this week is from
Abby grossberg when she was on speaking
with Nicole Wallace right she said that
there are 90 tapes that I have that
Dominion does not have
and then we learned on uh the beat with
Ari melber that at least well probably
many more than just one tape but the one
tape that their lawyer gave to Ari
melbert to play on the show was the
conversation between
um Maria Bartiromo and Ted Cruz on how
they plan to actually you know plan this
coup so there's at least one of those
tapes of the 90 tapes and I wouldn't be
surprised if there's a handful of other
tapes that incriminate many other people
so you know this is these are new
details uh I'm not sure how far along
the case is right now or an
investigation for that one but I mean
like
the fact that these new details are
coming I really feel like Abby grossberg
is more or less The Smoking Gun to Fox
News and is now
finding her you know because the topics
are related right and now finding her
her way to be involved in these other
investigations which is you know the the
Jan six
so
it's not looking good for Trump and
certainly not looking good for Ted Cruz
um I don't know if anything will happen
to Ted Cruz um you know but well we've
got Ted Cruz here on bonehead of the
week but I want to show you this first
this is Mike Pence trying not to be
caught on camera uh coming out of the
grand jury how do we not get caught on
camera we drive in an SUV with uh tinted
windows right if you notice if you
notice this light is green they run a
red light here for Mike Pence watch this
all the [__] in the intersection
and there's Mike
wow they ran a red light
that is illegal that is illegal roped
along I brought the law and but that
seems to be seems to be on on it's kind
of uh yeah on brand for that
Administration no absolutely well let's
go to the DM speaking of uh Senator Ted
Cruz and the tapes
um can you find the um the link for the
video uh of the one with the Marita by
moretto is that he said by moretto Romo
as I as I remember I I uh I called her a
Muppet character I hope nobody gets
offended
and my what was that for the the Tucker
Carlson getting fired because she makes
a cameo in there and so does that clip
and I called uh I said boxed wine lover
Janine Pirro and Muppet character Maria
Bartiromo
was like I had to go to YouTube and I
was like Maria Bartiromo pronunciation
you know or you sometimes you go to
Google and like Google will
automatically know which person you're
talking about and then you'll hear me
like ah Bartow Romo got it okay
um so let's let's see if we can find
this Ted Cruz Cape yeah um it's a record
it's conversation so tell the audience
because this has to do with the the
expert user and Fox News and Fox News
tried to gag her with a lawsuit and she
filed a counter lawsuit and they
actually dropped theirs
um and that's where these tapes come
from and this isn't the only recording
that she has and I don't think it's the
only recording that Jack Smith has um
has made sure to subpoena and get in his
possession of so so no Talent how many
other lawmakers and Fox News
personalities or Fox News producers had
been saying this [__]
um but so basically it's investigating
this yeah the reason the reason it's
such a big deal is so you've got you've
got uh Abby grossberg who has a lawsuit
against Fox for she has actually two
lawsuits one is around a workplace that
is uh for harassment
there was anti-Semitism
um you know racism there's sexist
misogynistic comments that were made
uh you can read excerpts from that if
you want um there's also the lawsuit
against Fox News for coercing her into
lying
about her what she should say for her
testimony right and so some of the stuff
was like
um yeah because you're what what you're
saying is is that that the the fox
lawyers were trying to get her testimony
to be a certain way not the truth but
trying to coerce her testimony yeah and
so they wanted her to say certain things
and she was she was talking about her
her experience when she was asked about
uh Tucker Carlson using the c word right
describing women as c word [__] the word
is [__] yeah yeah the word is kind of
see you next Tuesday and well I actually
Tony you're gonna get canceled man yeah
probably I know I know listen here's the
thing is that is that um
this is one thing that I think
um is important in this lawsuit in this
case because even though Tucker Carlson
was using the word [__] in a derogatory
fashion
um I actually believe there's more to
this story and actually believe the
reason why Abby uh the ex-producer she's
not some sort of you know woke leftist
as they want to paint her this is a
situation where the lawyers were trying
to get her to lie and the thing that she
knew that maybe they didn't know or
something is that she had all these
recordings that would show that she was
lying so she did not want to put herself
in criminal liability here by by
perjuring her and she's obviously
someone's evidence too she's not like
some woke leftist she was someone who
actually so she worked for Maria
Bartiromo right and what happened was
there was a there was a a job
opportunity to be a producer on Tucker
Carlson tonight and she was like this
would be great because even in the
interview with Nicole Walsh they were
like she was like why did you go work
for him she was like well I I'd have
more responsibility of you know bumping
pay I'd be in charge of this and this
and this and this and it was uh it was
an opportunity that I could not pass up
and so she was like I took I took the
shot and I went for it and and my life
what I later found out my life was a
living hell between the main producer on
the show and also uh Tucker cross and
she's like they made my my life it was
awful it was terrible right um and then
it wasn't until after Jan six and things
started happening where she's like I you
know and especially as they started to
show the Jan sex tapes because she she
was fired in March so for everyone this
is like a very recent development that
happened
uh and it's one of those things like
dude
you know
like you never want to [__] over someone
especially someone who has or knows
secrets or inside
details of of your like team and your
organization and she specifically while
working with Maria Bartiromo she had she
had recordings because this one that
we're about to play is from January 2nd
2021 before January 6 takes place before
the Insurrection Ted Cruz is talking to
Maria Bartiromo and they're talking
about how they plan to actually execute
this coup
and she had tapes from there
it's just one of those things where it's
like
again I really believe she's The Smoking
Gun and a lot of this because I think
leading up to the Dominion case
realizing what exactly she had and they
didn't even have it all and that's why
they settled probably with dominion and
that's probably why smart manic is going
to get just as much or more uh foggy
Ozark points out here Tony you need to
use the c word on dudes I absolutely
will use the c word on dudes yeah and
the reason why I'm not scared of the
word [__] is because we have a lot of
people in Australia who watch this show
they get up way early in the [__]
morning to watch this show and [__] is
not that bad of a word over there but
let me show you
um I mean you can even say Ted [__] Ted
Cruz is a [__] and you could say can
[__] cruise I don't know Cancun Cruise
Cancun Cruise
can coup Cruz is a [__] let's listen to
him
[__] his way into an Insurrection let's
listen where he doesn't think it's going
to get out he's just talking to someone
who he sees as an ally in this cause
Maria bartaromo in advance about
overthrowing the race with this fake
commission and using the claims of fraud
which remember on tape Ted Cruz said
we're not standing up in court
who's Society
Andre
results of that permission and what they
find and if they found
incredible evidence of Fraud and
undermines confidence in the Electoral
results in any given State they would
report on that okay so again this is
this is a private conversation now you
have to remember this is prior to Ted
Cruz's interview going on her show and
talking openly about this commission
that doesn't exist it's [__] fake
it's not real it's all [__] it was
just an effort to try to have another
way to convince Trump supporters that
they could overturn the election legally
and without consequence now Ted Cruz
actually tweeted about this commission
saying I went on live television and at
the beginning of the week when this
story broke I was like yeah no [__]
Sherlock we've been saying it for two
[__] years that you idiots were
trying to overtly overturn our vote in
our election you were trying to commit a
coup right out in the open we know that
we know what you were doing and this
phone call is the is the exact blueprint
of what how they were colluding with Fox
News to try to convince people to go to
the Capitol to create an Insurrection
because we know that it was Ted Cruz and
my Senator Josh Hawley not from the
state of Missouri he's a Missouri
Senator but he's not he doesn't live in
Missouri at [__] scumbag but those
two were the two key Senators who were
trying to challenge us on the floor to
get this to go back to the States like
Donald Trump just said in that stupid
[__] clip and and over the weekend
where he went to act like he was popular
somewhere where he's not he's not
[__] popular there no one likes him
uh besides maybe a few hundred people
that traveled to his rallies from from
rally to Rally to rally and Kid Rock and
Ted Nugent but who gives a [__] about
them
um what's this link um look at the start
count yeah I I yeah I seen that start
comment earlier oh oh uh
uh I want to remind you that my church
group is listening yeah
yeah well hey the church group is
listening if you can hear me Ted Cruz is
a [__] [__] [__] that's for sure
um I thought you were talking about the
other one this one is from earlier this
was from the a box Stephanie Butler I
don't know if she's still on the
broadcast here but she was on Facebook I
really don't care if she's on broadcast
she's like Tony's always criticizing
people looks like you factored you're
pathetic hey it's you are yeah you get
that one right
um but hey no no one ever said these
people were smart okay right well the
other thing too is I might be chubby but
listen since January 1st my goal was to
lose some weight and I've been doing a
damn good job I just broke this week I
just broke 20 pounds I've lost 20 pounds
oh [__] here yeah so Stephanie Stephanie
I am a chubby turd and you can kick
rocks yeah um and I'll make fun of
whoever the [__] I want and call him
whenever I want because I've been way
heavier than I am now so you you can
kiss my ass my fat ass to be exact hairy
fat fat hairy fat hairy anger Meister
drink your ass yeah can't okay okay so
uh we're I was I'm off track now okay
here we go oh
Alpha cook yeah [__] Ted Cruz right yeah
I mean we can all say [__] Ted Cruz
we're good with that we're good with
that uh this next guy he's this is the
first time he's ever appeared on bone
net of the week isn't it did you no no
no he's been on the show before yeah
because I was like I was like oh [__] do
I gotta make this bro what was that
I'm trying to remember what he said but
he's been on the show because I didn't
have to make his face this time was he a
contestant or was he like uh Alpha cuck
or DM he might have been one of the
others I I don't I would have to go
interesting I thought this was his first
appearance that's no no no he's that's
how many of these we've done yeah well I
mean we are on we are on episode what is
it 384 now oh man Jesus Christ yeah 384.
384. uh Stephen Crowder has made his way
look at this [__] picture with the
[__] bangs I always find the best
photos it's always this looks like my
old haircut that I had a couple months
ago poor Stephen Crowder I mean poor
really are we gonna say poor Stephen
Crowder this guy's gonna get everything
he deserves I'm gonna show you a video
I'm gonna show you a video where you
might think right I made it I made a
meme uh yeah about him today
why is Stephen Crowder
um our Alpha cook because Stephen
Crowder is he's a piece of [__] too he's
a yes he's a [__] he's a disgusting he's
a disco no relation to Trey Crowder no
relation to trigger that I know of I
don't think so I well I mean somebody
somebody asked if he was related I don't
think he's no I don't I don't think so
um but but Steven Crowder louder with
Crowder I'm a [__] douche
um this guy we found out and really
honestly no one should be surprised by
this
but we found out
that he is not only a piece of
disgusting piece of [__] but he's also
an abusive husband he's verbally and
emotionally abusive we don't know if
there's been he got divorced right is it
official that he's divorced or did she
just filed I don't know I don't think
it's official I think for people who
don't know who Stephen Crowder is this
might clue you in this is a very famous
meme uh it says change my mind he would
go to college campuses and he would sit
there and he would have a table and he
would he would start with an incendiary
complex issue and then he would say he
would say a really unpopular right-wing
opinion about it because he's a hateful
[__] bigot but then he changed my
mind right and then if anyone has seen
his stuff his arguments are all uh ad
hominems and they're also straw man
arguments so he builds this up and it's
unrelated and if and if you've seen if
you've seen him debate someone
especially college students and college
students are [__] owning him like
there's like [__] and ass handed back
to him uh he then attacks their physical
appearance uh says that they're dumb or
or comments on some other attribute
about them and as a way to dismiss and
say oh this isn't a legitimate person
they shouldn't be taken seriously and
that's how you know that's a very big
strategy on the right is when they
cannot make a point against you to win
they can actually debate and present
facts then they immediately Resort and
fall back to calling someone ugly fat
like we saw earlier uh through that
comment from that nasty lady
um and also you see them say oh you're
you know just a variety of things
uh that are that make that actually
reveal and expose this person to seem
you know even more uh uh or like less
authentic uh fake
um you know terrible whether the bigoted
racist whatever
um so there's this meme which is this
this is uh while Kalyn made this this
morning this is his wife
um and she says yeah I left him no
changing my mind which is a great take
on the meme uh by the way actually you
know a bunch of trolls have have made
this meme of me too and I forget what it
said
um but they they they put me in this
meme it's a famous meme that you put
people in uh about this stuff but
um okay so the thing is there's a tape
and of a ring and it's their private
ring how did that get out into the here
here's your ears is this your version of
it yeah that's my version yeah so this
is this is that's actually Stephen
grater there yeah yeah
um and it says I mean honestly it's one
of those it's one of the those moments
where you're like hey here's a photo I
put out there or a meme or a video or
whatever and it's now coming back to
bite me in the ass
and Stephen Crowder from what we've seen
in this video and you guys will see it
too is he's an emotionally
and verbally abusive husband actually
that's not the video I'm gonna show it's
hard and the reason why oh you're gonna
show the Candace Owens one the other one
okay I know why you're not gonna show
the other one okay well I mean listen
it's hard to understand what they're
talking about in the context him and his
wife are fighting on the patio and
they're talking about the car and
groceries and he's basically saying you
should be a subservient wife right and
you're not he's like you don't love me
you don't love me because you won't be
you know the one line the one line in
there that's like oh [__] man I wish I
could you know uh I I hope Karma comes
to get you on this one is when he's what
she's talking and he and he says watch
it watch it and that right there is all
you you don't even need to hear anything
else in the conversation but you hear
the tone in that phrase watch it is
enough that you need to know
um
I want to show this clip here oh yeah
this is from his show now this is from a
while back on louder with Crowder I just
want to show this moment so everyone
gets a good idea of who he is and like
that's some history on him maybe it's
only 18 seconds but maybe to give a good
idea about who Stephen crowd is listen
really carefully I'm afraid frankly I
used to have a bad temper I'm afraid of
it coming back I'm afraid of Mr Hyde
rearing is ugly bisexual head that was a
that was a short phase uh what what what
what what what was that
did he say I think he said let me rewind
it Mr Hyde let's listen Frederick coming
back I'm afraid of Mr Hyde rearing his
ugly bisexual head that was a that was a
short phase
um no I'm afraid so and just to give you
an idea of who he is the and and this is
what I believe a lot of their hatred is
of the lgbtq community yeah is that
they've been convinced that um whatever
feelings that they're suppressing and
and projecting that they project hate
onto the people that that they're trying
to suppress inside of them and you know
again I I I'm not here to say one way or
the other what Stephen grater is or
isn't he's a bigoted piece of [__] for
sure
um I'll say that but also he knocks on
the transgender Community for having
General affirming um surgery which he
apparently in these tapes and stuff and
then this investigation into his you
know who else has had a gender affirming
surgery who's in uh here we go man it is
[__] Alpha of all alpha males out
there
The Rock oh my God he had he had surgery
on his pectoral muscles because they he
he genetically like his own body
biologically however you want to put it
could not form the shape of his pectoral
muscles that he wanted so he went in and
got cosmetic surgery to cut away so that
there was more of like a shelf
appearance to his pecs right
and so that was years ago years ago well
he's I'm gonna I'm gonna tell you
something here honestly a lot of people
do a lot of things to change their
appearance okay we cut our hair I I trim
my beer a certain way so my face is
shaped a certain way
um I this morning when when I was
thinking about the show this morning and
this this idea that we we you know we
shouldn't be changing how we are or how
we look like I mean this sounds stupid
but
I shaved my shoulders because I'm hairy
and I don't want hair poking out on my
shoulders I get little random hairs
right now that's easy to take care of I
don't have to have surgery to to take
care of that it's just a small razor but
but I'll tell you that I could go get a
procedure done like laser hair remover
or something I I have a scar on my face
right here from poison ivy that I would
really love to get rid of so I mean but
but again a lot of people men get hair
plugs Donald Trump wears lifts in his
shoes which is in the surgery but it
makes him appear taller he wears a
girdle to make him appear thinner this
is such a bunch of [__] that you expect
that you expect that someone else can't
do what you're doing where Stephen
Crowder gets some sort of gender
reconfirming surgery where his pectorals
look a different way and then he knocks
on someone else for wanting to appear to
or appear to be the way they want to
appear The Rock doesn't run around
because the difference between the
rocketing uh surgery on his pecs and
Stephen Crowder I believe that is that
rock doesn't run around demeaning people
who who do the same thing who want to to
change their appearance
um speaking of changing their appearance
watch watch here where union workers
this is this is a while back this is
Stephen grater here watch how they try
to rearrange his face
um watch this
[Applause]
okay so this was originally edited by
Stephen Crowder and they take out where
he actually instigates this fight
because in court Stephen Crowder tried
to file [__] charges on this guy yeah
and in court they threw it out because
the actual video evidence the real video
evidence was that Steven Crowder started
this fight and this guy of course are
you gonna tell me that a [__] Alpha
cook like this [__] shows up to
a a rally or a protest and isn't going
to push someone around because he wants
that [__] footage he wants to be the
victim he wants like oh no I'm the
victim I'm so oppressed I'm I'm the one
who's getting beaten up and it sounds
like also if you're a [__] alpha male
like you claimed me wouldn't you have
been able to [__] knock these guys on
the ground stop taking hits like a
little [__] well I'm gonna say I'm
sometimes I'm just not against a Nazi
getting punched I'm just saying dude I
mean like look if you if you started
right you start you go like here's the
other thing too Stephen Crowder and
other people show up to these places to
intentionally start something right they
want to get it on tape they want to get
that ooh spicy controversial moment they
want they want the fight they want the
division the same reason that Tucker
Carlson does what he does in the [__]
show so he shows up to this thing wants
to start a fight gets into a fight and
is like oh no they no no no no no
speaking victims man you should to me's
victims with their maganomics well
usually he shows up at college campuses
right and he approaches you know young
people he thinks that's going to be an
easy way right but then he approaches
these these full-grown men who are
[__] who are who are you actually
work with their hands every [__] day
you beat the [__] out of Stephen Crowder
right beat that live and not scared to
beat the [__] out of him yeah if he
needs to be beating the [__] out of um
you know I think I just remembered why
Stephen Crowder had been on bone end of
the week do you remember uh when uh
daily
um
yes yes the date daily wire Ben
Shapiro's Nazi rag the daily Wire yeah
yes and 50 million dollars and then they
were spreading false information about
each other and this sort of thing while
Candace Owens
um went after Steven gretter she's with
the daily wire of course she has her
stupid [__] show on that Nazi wire
um and I I just love when right Wingers
uh eat each other it's like a [__]
sandwich eating a [__] sandwich and it's
so tasty let's watch
well again going back to the powder it's
not just a daily wire it's David Landau
it's then the computer it's Jared Monroe
formerly known as not gay Jerry people
that are locked into ndas are not
allowed to speak about the abuse that
they endured by Stephen Crowder it's
Owen Benjamin it's now his wife okay so
if you don't know these names and the
reason why you don't is because these
are stupid obscure people in right wing
media right yeah and that's that's why
that's why I've honestly never heard of
any of those nope but you know what it's
juicy so let's keep going do you believe
that all of these various different
parties the majority of them who have
never spoken to each other I've never
spoken to spend the computer I've never
spoken to David Laut Landau I've never
spoken to Hillary Crowder I've never
spoken to Owen Benjamin do you believe
that all of these people as is the
paranoid narrative that Stephen Crowder
is presenting are working maybe in in
collusion with big Tech to try to
destroy him or or do you believe it's
plausible that Stephen Crowder is just a
monster
so there she is gone Stephen grinder
monster but she's a monster calling
another person a monster isn't that
great well you know the framing of her
argument is like Stephen Crowder isn't
isn't the result of big Tech going after
him like look you're kind of giving away
your own game when you're doing this and
that's why I'm that's why I encourage
you that's why I want to show you when
they eat each other when the [__]
sandwich eats the [__] sandwich it's
fantastic it's just I mean it really is
one of those things when you when you
hear someone say is it really do you
think it's this conspiracy of big Tech
or is it actually because this person is
she's like awesome razor right it's like
the simplest answer is the answer right
and so when you look at this it's like
do you think that 80 million people
committed voter fraud or do you think
that people just didn't want to vote for
Trump right so whenever they're like oh
the election was stolen or this is then
it's like um let's really look at this
what do you think actually happened what
do you think is it is it some conspiracy
or is it this person's a [__] [__]
and a monster right well here I'll give
you one screenshot of the ring.com
footage yeah that has come to light here
on the back patio the Crowders house
um as his wife Hillary you see here
um she's she's a very pregnant here on
the back porch and she's trying to leave
and the quote is this is from Stephen he
says Hillary just think of how boxed in
you've made me
dude you you married her yeah like what
why didn't Stephen Crowder also like
people can do this whatever uh but
didn't he say he was like oh I married
the love of my life and I waited until
marriage to have sex and again you could
totally do that if you want to but this
guy's like telling other people how they
should have lived their lives and have
their marriages and all this stuff and
this guy's like in [__] socks and a
schlub of a [__] human in the back
patio area telling his wife who's
pregnant uh that she can't use the car
[__] if she I mean dude she's very
pregnant I would be like no here look
I'll drive you to the [__] grocery
store you should they only have one card
that's that because when I'm watching
that video I'm like number one I don't
really know what the hell they're
talking about because you're fighting
over something and well it sounded like
obvious what they're fighting over well
it was fighting over the car and the
groceries but that's not the reason why
it was the there was a few things so it
was the the car using the car and the
groceries and then he wanted to know
like when will you be back when are you
coming back she's like I'm back when I'm
back he's like that's not a good enough
answer I want to know when you're coming
back and so this whole thing of of him
being like gaslighting being verbally
and and emotionally abusive to this
woman who is [__] pregnant right I
don't know what their relationship is
beyond this little like three-minute
snippet that we got but it's not good
right it doesn't look good at all
especially for this guy who had a video
earlier in the week that was like people
are talking about my divorce you know
Candace Owens I may take legal uh legal
kind of steps forward in terms of how to
how to deal with this but uh this
divorce is no fault of my own it's not
my fault it's because in the state of
Texas well here's the clip yeah here's
the clip here's the clip that he had on
the show about complaining about how
he's forced to get divorced because of
the laws in Texas won't make it to where
she can't divorce if you look
if you don't say [__] don't complain
about you right like that's what that's
what the problem is with all these
right-wing [__] Nazi Alpha cucks they
say [__]
to be like oh look this is the truth you
can almost 100 percent believe that it's
not going to be the truth and they're
actually the ones who are at fault okay
what's happening well this makes sense
NJ here on YouTube says um they were
fighting because they wanted her to walk
the dog uh he wanted her to walk the
dogs and put the gloves on to put
medication on the dogs and she didn't
want to touch the magic because she was
pregnant that makes sense because they
kept talking about gloves in the car and
the dogs I'm like what in the [__] is
going on with the gloves and the dog but
even she's like I won't even take she's
like I won't even take the car I'll call
someone to drive and then he's like no
you won't get an Uber and yeah it it I I
I honestly because of the context and
the back and forth it just it was like
it was almost like there's underlying
context right like they're fighting
already the guy is lying an [__]
right yeah well just watch this clip
about how he's complaining that the
state of Texas allows his wife to
divorce him when he doesn't want her to
uh I have been living with a proverbial
boot on my neck for going on years in
Christ
uh since 2021 I've been living through
what has increasingly been a horrendous
divorce now let me say on the outset to
be clear there is no infidelity any kind
of physical abuse at all on either side
and no yet this was not
uh my choice my then wife decided that
she didn't want to be married anymore I
wonder why and in the state of Texas
that is completely permitted
it's been the most heartbreaking
experience of my life oh poor guy sounds
like you caused it poor guy I mean
here's the thing here's the thing in a
lot of states and it should be every
state if you don't want to be married to
someone then you should be able to not
be married to that person anymore I
don't give a [__] what the reason is
um it's just it's easy to get a marriage
license it should be just as easy to
break that [__] marriage license so
but also like the idea that he's like oh
like there was no infidelity or physical
abuse like look I I don't know man I I
don't want to take you at your word
because clearly every time somebody does
hear you say something it's the complete
opposite right you attack certain people
you say disgusting horribly divisive
things you say oh no it wasn't uh it's
because she wanted to yeah well if we
really look at the [__] full picture
here and we just got a three minute clip
I wonder why because I can almost
guarantee this three-minute clip or so
that they showed of this ring doorbell
footage right this camera footage isn't
the first time that happened right super
comfortable in the way that he talked to
her he was super comfortable in the way
that he was uh verbally and emotionally
abusive trying to Gaslight her into
saying oh it's your fault right you know
what you know what he gets me you know
what gets me the most about the whole
back and forth because when you're in a
relationship with someone sometimes you
you say things right right
um and in that moment where he has the
clip on his show where he's like the
state of Texas is making it to where she
can divorce me and I can do nothing
about it but in the clip of the Ring
footage he says at one point he doesn't
love her she's like I love you and she's
like I don't love you and I'm like why
why would you want I mean Stephen
honestly man my question to you is why
would you want to be so [__]
miserable why are you why what are you
doing why are you trying to be like is
that the house like you know especially
oh we got to talk about the nuclear
family the n-word not that N word but
the other N word let's talk about we
have to have a father a mother and kids
and a friend [__] bright red door and
a swing set in the front yard with a
white picket fence and a golden
retriever like all of these [__]
Republicans want to push that type of
you know look man not everyone wants to
get married not everyone wants to have
kids not everyone can have kids right
and even when they [__] say hey I'm
gonna people want to have kids and not
get married there's like exactly there's
all sorts of things right and even some
people are like look I can't have kids
but I want to adopt kids right and you
look at what happened earlier this
weekend Margaret Taylor green coming
against uh
um I forget her name but the the I think
it was the teachers union
um and went against Herman said like oh
well you're not a real mother you're not
a biological mother right you're you
don't actually count and it's like even
when
even when you're like hey look man I'm
bringing in that Christian mentality and
I'm caring for other people who can't
care for themselves because other people
decided they couldn't take that on right
you look at that and you say even when
even when that happens they go oh you
know what [__] you as the as the
Christian Republican they say no no you
don't count you're not real you're not
an actual mother uh that kid doesn't
have a mom because you're not the real
one right like
Roderick you're always bringing the best
ones cuckle doodle do
um but I will say one last thing and
because I've I mentioned it over the
last several weeks
um man I got so many Clips I want to
play on the subject of this whole Pro
mother woman thing where they're like oh
we're pro mother woman type [__]
um where they want women to be mothers
they don't want to be anything else and
they're trying to sell it as a pro-woman
message which is [__] stupid and
they're leaning into this I've been
telling you this is going to be they
tried Dei and it fell flat on its face
right they tried to Dei like a month ago
and we all shut it down like di [__]
that [__] di same CRT and and so they
kind of walked away from that [__] now
they're doing the whole Pro woman mother
thing and um
by the way on the rake stepping thing
yeah
we got a merch Design coming and it's
not here yet I I was hoping we'd have it
today but we will we should have it by
Monday in the merch store but it's it's
going to be something to do with a rake
wink wink wink I I'm Roderick I might
have to make something of this cuckold
doodle too too I don't know you guys are
the best audience you come up with the
best things okay I love to keep going on
Steven Crowder but who wants to talk
about that [__] anymore
um let's go to the next [__] and the
bonehead of the week winner Tucker
Carlson
whoa oh man is there anything that we
could touch on Tucker that we haven't
already this week but you know I mean
honestly the end of the week he you know
I
poor attacker he's gonna
so I I you know what I want to show you
I want to show you I want to show you a
clip of Tucker that we haven't shown yet
and it's not of cucker it's about Tucker
um and it's actually Megan Kelly
I I am so surprised that Megan Kelly
like considering Megan Kelly in Fox's
news is like past with [__] Roger
Ailes and all of them and Donald Trump
you think that Megan Kelly would be like
I don't want anything to do with anyone
who's ever been associated with Fox News
you would think that right but I don't
know what the foul brainwashed kind of
mentality you have
well here is Megan Kelly on her Sirius
XM show the Megan Kelly show where she's
talking about
um Tucker Carlson not being fired again
it's the semantics of it like we were
saying with Ed but here she's on reserve
he's on the bench he wasn't fine it's
all [__] he's fired they did they
took him out of his spot let's listen
and um have a lot of thoughts about it I
wanna
I think break some news for you Tucker
Carlson hasn't actually been fired
he's still an employee of the Fox News
Channel what happened was Suzanne Scott
called him she's the CEO on Monday
morning and said
um he was not going to be allowed to do
any more shows huh what what could Poss
what a person could possibly say
um when you say that like um maybe
you're like um you're done yeah that's
one
um we gotta fulfill our contracts so
we're gonna try to figure it out but
you're not doing your show anymore yeah
that could be another way that you would
say it
um because I would agree that the CEO of
Fox especially if Rupert Murdoch was
watching from the security footage in
his in his red velvet robe
um eating his oatmeal and yogurt
um because you know that's what you do
you eat oatmeal and yogurt when you're a
thousand years old and you're trying to
and you have that one hard-boiled egg
that sits on a little cup and then
you're like
right it's probably got it's probably
got uh caviar uh oh yeah yeah it's
actually an ostrich egg uh with caviar
that's kind of absolutely that's the
secret of living two thousand right yeah
you eat little baby ostrich eggs right
exactly you have you you make uh little
abortion uh ostrich omelets and you make
those and you eat the ostrich abortions
in an omelette fashion with the caviar
on top but Megan Kelly here is after
semantics here because she's trying kind
of break news that Tucker Carlson hasn't
been fired now
what the actual cases well let me play
the rest of the clip and then I'll tell
you what the [__] that she's trying
to spend here and that he had been
kicked out of his company email and now
they're going to have to negotiate and
exit
um some reporting to me uh suggests that
she said it's going to be an amicable
parting
right isn't it parting exit I mean
everything you were not you were kicked
out of your company email you weren't
allowed to log in you were told by the
CEO of Fox that oh look you can't do
your show anymore and we're gonna have
to figure out how to don't show up on
the premises we're gonna come get our
cameras from your home studio because
there are cameras and you're gonna have
to use your cell phone to post a video
online this is awesome but also it's
just like oh they have to negotiate and
exit yeah that's how that [__] goes
to contract it's not a contract and they
have to figure out who's like if this
was just cause or not right did they
fire him because of the things he said
the things he did or is this because
Murdoch was like look I can't have this
headache anymore and you've already cost
me Millions if not potentially billions
of dollars with this new upcoming
lawsuit not to mention the one that Abby
grossberg has against us on the [__]
work uh harassment lawsuit right so you
you look at this and you say
um is it is it uh you know on pause on
the bench
fired him you're fired you were fired
you were fired you were fired well let's
see how many other ways she can say
fired here
um completely catching Tucker off guard
but Tucker's not fired nope that's my
information oh that he still needs to
negotiate the exit and that right now
he's not free to launch a podcast or a
digital show or negotiate with other
employers
because he's still under contract they
pulled his show off the air they also
fired his executive producer Justin
Wells so he tried to find out why they
wouldn't tell him they refused to tell
him why because they don't have to they
they probably don't have to but also
even if I mean like I wouldn't be
surprised look we're letting you go for
whatever and again it comes back to like
if there was just cause or whatever
which is up to whatever the contract
stipulates
but again
everything she said uh was removed from
company email didn't have access he you
know wasn't able to do his show he was
taken off the air these are all things
that sound like
right well they all mean that right now
here here's what she's trying to say
tucker was fired
but Fox News still has a contractional
obligation to him and what Fox News
wants to try to do is make sure Tucker
doesn't say anything out of line after
the contract I mean they have they say
reportedly there is a uh a a a dossier
oh Jesus of dirt on him from Fox News
which again is like do you mean they're
like hanging this over him is that what
well is that what they're trying to the
narrative that they're trying to spend
here well no no I'm thinking like in
terms of like why he can't I mean if you
were smart in any case regardless you
would never say anything disparaging
about your former employer especially if
your Contracting your payout is on the
line but reportedly there's this dossier
of of uh
you know not saying it's blackmail but
very not good things but also it's like
do you think they really had to dig that
deep or were they just like oh yeah we
just watched a show and he said it all
there on TV right like
it's just it's one of those things again
where Republicans are like oh I'm the
victim I didn't do anything it's like
you literally said these things you did
those
they're Liars they're liars and here's
the other reason why you know the liars
is because Tucker posted that video that
we showed the other day and I think we
should have asked right we showed we
showed some um views of it and I think
there's I think it's got like 20 million
views on Twitter like that's the count
and it's got 70 million actual views of
the Tweet not the video and they're
lying about that and like oh Tucker's
got a bigger audience on Twitter than
they do want than he does on yeah but
most of them they were [__] mocking
him and making fun of him those views
but the other thing too the other thing
too that I want people to understand is
that Tucker Carlson when he does
negotiate his firing as Megyn Kelly puts
it when he when he finally is out of the
contract and fox is out of the contract
he's going to be able to go somewhere
else but I'll I'm gonna tell you a
prediction here and you can doubt me but
Tucker Carlson is never going to be the
same Tucker Carlson that you've seen
before and the reason why is because
Rupert Murdoch owns the 8 PM hour at Fox
News he owns it Fox News controls it and
they didn't control the creative content
in that 8 PM hour with Tucker Carlson
under that contract and now they're
going to own it again so that's the
reason why they fired Tucker I don't
give a [__] if I had if I had to guess I
would say that we know you know to what
Ed was talking about is like he had
shows that were you know attempting to
be more reporting or fair or balanced or
whatever and then he realized like many
Republicans do is that if you go for the
very uh divisive uh chaos driven uh
hateful you know ideology you get a lot
more people drawn in it's like why
Republicans are more drawn to the image
of disgust than they are anything else
and I wouldn't be surprised if now that
Tucker he knows he knows exactly what
drives traffic and gets people to watch
and so when you look at it uh I wouldn't
be surprised if Tucker takes that same
same type of narrative and talking kind
of point of view and goes further with
it because he can never go back if he
goes back then people will be like oh
you're such a [__] [__] ass [__]
you're a little cuck you you bend to the
you've been to the corporate overlords
yeah but but Gabe Sanchez he's got to go
further I'm gonna push back on you a
little bit here here's the here's why
because
um his his little video was so
um unenthusiastic it was Tucker Carlson
like but he didn't lean into anything
but he couldn't say anything yeah but
here's the thing any platform he goes on
they're gonna make sure that Tucker
Carlson can't cost them 800 million
dollars okay that's true that's that's
what and and here's the deal is that
Tucker Carlson is going to go completely
independent he's going to open his own
production he's going to try to prob
possibly have his own website his own
service he's probably not going to do it
through uh the daily uh the daily wire
or he's probably not going to go through
any network that is existing right now
he's going to try to capture the
audience himself it's going to be a
small audience it'll be a huge
Subscription Service he'll have a huge
email list but he'll be talking to much
less people and no one will hear him we
will very rarely play his Clips because
he will walk back a lot of his [__] if
he does go on a network I will agree
with you if he goes completely
independent he will say whatever he
wants but he'll it'll be irrelevant
because no one will be listening to him
because everyone will be listening to
the 8 PM hour on Fox News and whoever
that is I'm telling you that it's
exactly what's going to happen I I know
right-wing media and I'm telling you
that 8 PM hour they're going to find
someone that's going to say crazy ass
[__] in that 8bm hour to keep the
eyeballs on that 8 PM hour and Rupert
Murdoch wants to make sure to have more
creative control over the APM hour that
he didn't have with Tucker Carlson and
it cost Fox 800 million it's going to
cost him more in the long run and that's
why they just cut bait and run and if
anyone thinks I I keep seeing this that
oh Fox made a huge huge mistake cutting
Dr Carlson come on man they they said
the same [__] about Bill O'Reilly when
Bill O'Reilly left they were like oh
that's the end of Fox News and then when
Tucker came most people were like oh
who's the bow tie [__] and then
he leaned into the whole propaganda
thing it was successful in the 8 P.M
hour I mean people need to know that
Rupert Murdoch like
in order to and I had a there in in my
what was that on this there was a line
that I wrote and I cut when I was
editing because I was like oh no this
makes it seem like I want to give Fox
News a second chance here but basically
my my tip I was like for Murdoch if
you're listening
uh start fresh man cut the whole [__]
team and start from scratch because all
of these people are are full uh they
cause complete headaches and they cost
you too much money but I cut it because
I was like oh no this is making making
it seem like I want to legitimize Fox
News right now but that's the
unfortunate truth right like you're
always gonna have bigotry and you're
always gonna have this hatred that is
like at the core of Fox News and Rupert
Murdoch is that person that is going to
Foster that right he's going to bold in
that he's going to make sure that the
people who are put on that time slot or
whatever other time slots are in the day
is going to be someone who is going to
push the button will say push the button
in quotes because really it's just like
pushing the hateful ideology but he's
the one that's driving the ship to say
like look you know Lachlan do this uh
you know Suzanne do this right like he's
still got his influence into what they
should do and they're still going to
have those problems with or without
Tucker Carlson so at the end of the day
they're gonna find someone to replace
them yes but they're always going to be
this place where people go
to get that uh discussion that hate in
that device yes well because before
Tucker Carlson there was Bill O'Reilly
and Bill O'Reilly's a disgusting racist
Jesus Christ they'll always find someone
that's willing to [__] sell their
soul to the devil and say this stupid
[__] and the other reporting out that's
out there in the New York Times is that
the day before the trial it appeared the
Dominion lawyers were trying to get
Tucker Carlson on the stand and the
reason why Fox it's another reason why
Fox probably wanted to settle for 800
and they cut bait with Tucker because
they don't want that [__] on the
stand with smart manic yeah if they go
all the way
they could and here's the thing too all
of that could have been avoided these
text messages these emails all of these
like leaks that came out everything
could have been avoided if at the very
beginning when the lawsuit was presented
and Foxy was like oh now we're gonna pay
that [__] we didn't do anything we're
not at faulting and they're like okay
fine and then discover every process
happens and these text messages come out
it's revealed that they said this and
they said this there's a bunch of
redacted stuff that is now coming to
light that uh of more of stuff that he
said they realized that it was one of
those moments where like [__] we should
have from the very beginning
just settle this none of this would have
been public right no one would have
known this but that probably would have
took less than 800 million oh totally
they would have been like a poor
Discovery they would have turned way
less like 100 million 50 million let's
do it right [__] yeah oh yeah they would
also with this you look at it and you're
like oh my God it is another one of
these moments where Republicans do not
think in the long term they think in the
[__] short term oh we're gonna own
the libs we're gonna get them we're
gonna we're gonna [__] own them so
badly and it's like you guys Stephen
Crowder right even to come back to him
he's like oh man I didn't do anything
I'm not at fault my wife's the one who
wanted to divorce me and then you find
out through yashar on Twitter he gets
exclusive ring camera footage and it
dictates or it states the opposite
reveals the opposite of what the
narrative is that they're trying to push
so it's like whenever somebody comes
after a Republican or the right wing
conservatives whatever
and says
hey there is this crime or there is this
thing that you guys did
and they say no no we didn't do it you
can probably assume that they did do it
and the further that they fight it the
more that they want to just go against
it and be stubborn is going to mean that
at the end it's going to blow up and
reveal even more than they wanted to no
it's going to cause more damage to their
brand their name their image money the
bank accounts whatever it might be it's
going to be
terrible for them and every time it
happens I [__] laugh because I'm like
oh man [__] karma's a [__] right
like you [__] deserve it baby right
steppers I got some breaking news in the
Tucker Carlson before we go to the music
um this is him getting ready apparently
uh for his next performance this is uh
Tucker Carlson uh getting ready for his
next performance [__] is his four I mean
I know what it is but what the [__] is
this for I I don't know this is oh my
God it's so detailed yeah and the
eyebrows twitching God no man yeah I
just [__] man and breaking news Tucker
Carlson is getting ready for his next
appearance
all right Decker girls and you're the
winner of the bone end of the week or
[__] of the week whichever you want
to say
Gabe Sanchez let's give him his due
[Music]
[Applause]
oh Tucker Tucker Tucker you [__]
oh my God you know I couldn't have
happened getting fired Fox and just
couldn't happen to a better guy right I
know oh man the the late night the late
night commentary from a bunch of uh
comedians were they're like hey I think
Jimmy Fallon said as well as other
people they're like hey I'm Jimmy Fallon
and I was not fired from my show right
right but it's I mean it was I would
definitely say that everyone was in
complete shock that he that he got fired
I was excited that was a happy yeah no
that was a great day yeah
we were thinking of on Monday for the
the no we did we did that Ron DeSantis
thumbnail right and then and then like
five minutes later I was like this is
old news as soon as I posted it I saw
the talk I was like [__] me as soon as I
posted
Tacker had been fired so Tucker you're
the bone end of the week everyone stick
around we'll be right back after the
music for more announcements
[Music]
[Applause]
oh Decker Carlson bonehead of the week
that wasn't that was an easy one with
Tucker yeah way out ahead oh yeah he won
I mean look again we've talked about
this before where it's like during the
week you could have someone that comes
in at the very end
of
the week right you can have someone who
comes in Thursday afternoon and they win
it right but Tucker he Monday morning
before the show even started Monday
morning
that news broke and it was like yeah
he's gonna be on it and he probably has
a pretty good chance of [__] winning
I mean he won as Rob law says uh uh he
won by a [__] Landslide yeah he did oh
my god well he got out in front I
actually voted for Mike Pence to give
him it was a video I knew Tucker was it
more for Mike Pence or more for the fly
well I picked Mike Pence so I was like
well I better I I he better get at least
one vote and it might as well be mine he
got a few when I counted it did he okay
yeah well you know oh yeah it's a couple
it's a couple almost as many votes as
him and Trump got in them
2020 and 2016. I don't know I don't know
hey we got some great announcements here
for the Tony Michaels podcast pay
attention to the social media this week
and you go to the Tony michaels.com to
follow us everywhere because we're gonna
have rake merch
wink it's gonna have to do with
something about eating rake and I I
don't maybe we get the let me see if
I've got
the design here
um we have an initial design but I I'm
waiting on a new one no I don't have one
yet um I'm hoping we'll have a design
today uh she'll be watching over the
weekend for the rake merch just go to
uh
store.thetonymichaels.com that's
store.dtonymichaels.com here's a couple
examples of the merch you'll find over
there at store not the attorney
michaels.com again be paying attention
to the social media page we will be
posting as soon as that hits as soon as
it drops I'll be posting now so you guys
can go find that and we'll be announcing
it on Monday speaking of Monday don't
forget to subscribe here on YouTube so
you can watch on Monday you don't want
to miss a single episode we're live
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
on YouTube Twitter and twitch thank you
to everyone who who followed us on
Twitch this week we're up to 1018.
followers and we have a 118 subscribers
so thank you very much for linking your
Prime account we get a few dollars every
single month when you subscribe with
your Amazon Prime account and giving us
that one free subscription and you also
we get you have to re-subscribe every
month so thanks to everyone who has
resubscribed every month and this month
we really appreciate all the support
over on Twitch and if you haven't
already go over to Twitch and follow us
at Tony Michaels pod you can also again
link your Amazon Prime account you get
one free subscription with your Amazon
Prime account you can give it to us the
Tony Michaels podcast over there on
Twitch and we get a few dollars of Jeff
bezos's money also this weekend you're
not going to want to miss anything on
patreon go to what was that show.com uh
follow Gabe over there
see all the extras for the what was that
show you can go to patreon.com I am Gabe
Sanchez is that some exciting got some
exciting stuff happening this weekend we
got the Tucker Carlson one that hasn't
been public yet so you're going to check
that out go check it out and then not
only but I'm gonna have a follow-up
Tucker Carlson one where I [__] on that
[__] lame ass weak ass video that he
made from his [__] basement nice the
basement video and if while you're on
patreon.com listen up carefully while
you're on patreon.com go to Tony
Michaels it's patreon.com the Tony
Michaels after the show I'm gonna go
take a piss break maybe grab a snack and
then I'm gonna come back and edit but
here's what I'm gonna do while I'm
editing we're gonna do ask me anything
so we'll do ask me anything so you can
come in the chat so go to patreon.com
the Tony Michaels you'll be able to
participate and ask me anything and I
try to get to all the questions in the
30 minute period so if you asked a
question within the 30 minute period I
don't care what it is I'll answer it you
may not like the answer but I will so go
to patreon.com the Tony Michaels ask me
anything right after the show again
maybe 15 20 minutes yeah you know you
gotta go you know take a quick break the
key break turns into something else well
sometimes it happens you know I'm a
libtard so I sit down to pee you know
what I mean
I've had that have you ever had that
have you ever had that in your comments
like oh you look like you sit down to
pee sometimes I do yeah sometimes I do
when I'm also going taking a [__] yeah
yeah I mean I'd piss what I'm [__]
too yeah yeah it's crazy you can do two
things at once that's uh yeah well you
know
some people can also follow us on
Facebook speaking of taking a [__]
follow us over on Facebook at the Tony
Michaels
I hate Facebook I like my Facebook page
we got a lot of people over there that
engage on Facebook yeah yeah but I I'm
not a fan of Facebook I'm not even
really a fan of Instagram to tell you
honest truth
um it's clunky they made it more clunky
did you notice that the update that they
did it's honestly the last time I was on
Facebook I made a fake profile and then
I was doing some investigating into
George Santos so oh
is there going to be what was that from
your Facebook fake profile over there no
no I think I'm I covered most of it like
a lot of the stuff I did about the okay
the dog adoption the scammy and that's
in a previous episode of what was that
so if you haven't seen that check it out
um
patreon.com follow it you'll see all
those episodes over there go follow
Gabe's YouTube channel also uh you can
subscribe to his YouTube channel
youtube.com I am Gabe Sanchez so follow
that and you can see all those episodes
over there of what was that uh on his
channel you got anything else to end the
week anything think of anything it's
been man it's been a news-packed week we
missed a ton of [__] but I mean we could
we literally could stream for 10 hours a
day and not not catch it all yeah it's
just it's just not possible but I gotta
make money somehow man right now right
right so go to patreon.com I am Gabe
Sanchez so he can make a buck or two and
link your Amazon Prime account to Twitch
account thank you for all your support
really genuinely now we we do appreciate
all your support as this is our
full-time gig here uh streaming and
holding the right accountable every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central two full hours
YouTube Twitter twitch and that [__]
storm over at Facebook same time same
place on Monday
surf that [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon